Kenner wissen, wir müssen den letzten Mittwoch im Monat haben. Ihr schaut kurz in den Kalender und stellt fest, ja, das ist so. Der Blue Moon heute auf Fritz ganz im Zeichen des Chaos Computer Clubs. Chaos Radio. Drei Stunden lang, drei Stunden lang talken über ein ganz bestimmtes Thema heute Abend. Im Studio dafür Frank Rosengard und Andi Müller-Magun und meine Person Max von Malodki. Und das Thema stellt der Frank einfach ganz kurz vor.
Jo, Musik aus dem Netz, demnächst nur noch legal und bezahlt. E-Donkey, Casa, Nutella, Musik-Tauschbörsen geraten zunehmend ins Kreuzfeuer der Musikindustrie. Denn die unerlaubten Downloads bedeuten nach eigenen Angaben Millionen Verluste für die Plattenlabels. Aber es geht auch anders. Zumindest ein Anbieter kann mittlerweile einen wirklichen Erfolg verbuchen. Das Prinzip des Click-and-Download scheint ebenfalls zu funktionieren, wenn man für die heruntergeladene Musik bezahlen muss. Damit sind die Probleme aber noch lange nicht außer Welt, denn die gesaugten Stücke wollen vor der Weitergabe gesichert sein. Das Urheberrecht wurde kürzlich verschärft, aber es gibt es immer noch, die Privatkopie. Die 82. Sendung des Chaosradio auf Fritz beschäftigt sich heute mit der Zukunft dieser Systeme, die in nicht geringem Maße davon abhängt, wie attraktiv ihr das Prinzip des legalen Downloads findet.
Das ist das Thema heute Abend. Mehrfach kontaktbar sind wir hier im Studio, unter anderem über E-Mail 82... www.chaosradio.ccc.de, dahin könnt ihr wie üblich eure Fragen und eure Bemerkungen zu der heutigen Sendung schicken. Wir gucken das nicht in der Sendung an, das heißt, ihr müsst dann im Zweifelsfall auf eine Antwort noch warten, bis später, wenn ihr euch direkt melden wollt, direkt beteiligen möchtet, an diesem Thema, das sich heute Abend rund um Rechte und rechte Management, digitale Musikdownloads, legal oder illegal dreht. Dann ruft an 0331 77 97 110 und die erste Frage, die natürlich im Raum steht, angesichts der Tatsache, dass Apple einen unglaublichen Erfolg zu verzeichnen hat mit seinem Musikdownload-Dienst, der über iTunes 4 funktioniert, würdet ihr für Musikinhalte bezahlen wollen, wenn es denn geht? 0331 70 97 110. Da wird sich kurz geräuspert und wir sind wieder da im Chaosradio auf Fritz kurz nach 10. Die Sendung hat gerade erst begonnen. Thema heute Abend ist sehr, sehr vielfältig könnte man sagen. Denke mal, die drei Stunden werden verflucht. Viele Meinungen enthalten, aber es geht unter anderem auch darum, wie sich das Thema Inhalte entwickeln soll im Internet, insbesondere Musik. Mit dem Thema möchten wir einsteigen, denn die Frage ist, habt ihr Bock in Zukunft musikalische Inhalte zu bezahlen? Das heißt, wartet ihr vielleicht schon darauf oder sagt ihr, ey, die Leute lecken die da am Arsch. Ich möchte ganz gerne einfach meine Tauschbörse weiterhin benutzen, wie ich das tue, wenn dann da zwischendurch mal das falsche Musikstück sich dahinter verbirgt oder die Qualität scheiße ist, das ist mir egal. Und wenn ich der Musikindustrie damit schadenzufüge, ist es mir auch egal. Oder sagt ihr, nein, ich möchte ganz gerne meine Sachen kaufen und ich würde mir wünschen, dass das in näherer Zukunft auch funktioniert. 0331 70 97 1 1 0 im Studio heute Frank Rosengard, Andi Müller-Magun und meine Person Max von Malodki.
Also ich tue sehr völlig Musikdownlohn erst mal von kasa.de. Und da muss man, glaube ich, noch nicht bezahlen, glaube ich zum Glück. Und ich würde schon bezahlen, wenn jetzt es teurer werden würde ein bisschen. Aber ich würde sagen, es tut sich immer noch rechnen, wenn ich mir jetzt für ein Lied, was ich gut finde, mir vielleicht die ganze Platte kaufen müsste, die anderen Lieder voll scheiße sind.
Das heißt, du würdest lieber einzelne Lieder kaufen können?
Ja, für jetzt, weiß ich nicht. Jetzt überteuert, aber...
Was würdest du denn ausgeben? Was wärst du bereit auszugeben?
50 Cent maximal.
50 für ein Lied?
Ja, ein Titel.
Wie viel Lieder sind auf so einer CD drauf?
Kommt drauf an im Schnitt. So 10 bis 20 im Dreh.
Also auch so 10 Euro für eine CD?
Nein, aber da sind wir bei 7, 8 Euro. Das sind 16 Mark.
Und kaufst du denn jetzt auch CDs oder gar nicht?
Ich kaufe mir schon noch CDs. Ich hab's mir früher internetbestellt, aber es ist mir nach der Oma zu teuer geworden. Erstens, weil das Porto auch tierisch hoch ist. Manchmal brauchst du teurer als die CD manchmal.
Und warum kaufst du oder was ist an normalen richtigen CDs der Reiz für dich?
Ich bin eigentlich Musik aus den 80er-Fan und die bekommt man heute nicht mehr so leicht. Natürlich sind da auch Titel drauf, die nicht so schön sind, aber ich hab die CD, die vielleicht auch einen Wettermann wert hat.
Also so das Ganze mit Cover und Hülle und Aufdruck, Booklet, was auch immer.
Aber aktuelle Musik holst du dir sozusagen schon aus dem Netz?
Ja, also natürlich mir meistens runterladen, denn die gibt's schon.
Und gibt's da Sachen, wo du sagst, das find ich so cool, das kauf ich mir jetzt auch als CD? Oder sagst du da, was ich hab, hab ich?
Ja, zum Beispiel hab ich mir jetzt Tattoo, mir die CD gekauft, aber es gab auch die ja zum Unterladen, aber meistens auch die Qualität ein bisschen blöd und ich würde schon gute Qualität auch haben.
Ist dir das schon mal passiert, dass du was runtergeladen hast und das war qualitativ nicht so, wie das dir vielleicht gewünscht hättest?
Ja, oft schon eigentlich.
Was waren das dann so für Sachen? Einfach rauschig oder was war das?
Manchmal vielleicht auch im Mono, also ich weiß eigentlich immer, wenn Stereo angeboten wird, also Mono hatte ich schon, dann war das dumpf alles gewesen irgendwie, auch rauschen.
Das klingt so ein bisschen, als wenn das so mit Absicht reingestellt wurde von Plattenfirmen? Hast du dafür Verständnis, dass sie da quasi so eine Gegenwehr ergreifen, irgendwie um die Leute jetzt davon abzuhalten? Oder andersrum hält dich das davon ab? Also wenn du dir jetzt plötzlich zehn Stück runter lädst und davon sind jetzt irgendwie sieben in scheiß Qualität, würdest du es dann vielleicht irgendwann sein lassen oder?
Ich weiß nicht, es kommt immer auf die Situationen drauf an, wenn ich jetzt dein Lied unbedingt haben möchte. Und das gibt es da auch, aber ich will es mir jetzt herunterladen. Auch wenn es natürlich jetzt ein bisschen eine blöde Qualität ist.
Na klar, was soll.
Danke dir Tom für den Anruf. Tschüss, mach gut. Ihr könnt euch auch beteiligen an der Diskussion. Würdet ihr für Musikinhalte bezahlen wollen, wenn die qualitativ besser sind? Tom hat ja jetzt schon so ein paar Negativerfahrungen gemacht. Sei mal dahingestellt, ob die Plattenfirmen das von sich aus reingestellt haben oder ob das einfach einer war, der nicht ordentlich eine CD rippen konnte. 0331 77 97 110. Die Nummer vom Blue Moon heute Abend. Und am Telefon ist der Philipp. Hallo Philipp. Wow, mal was ganz Frisches.
Ja, erzähl mal.
Das haben sie auf Azeved vorgestellt. Da gab es solche Settel oder so und da kommt man sich das mal drauf durchlesen. Da müsste es eigentlich noch eine Webseite geben, nur die habe ich jetzt gar nicht in Kopf, vielleicht könnt ihr da mal nachgucken.
Ich gucke gerade mal. Potato-System Fraunhofer, naja. Aber erzähl doch mal.
Und zwar, das funktioniert so, wenn mir also ein Lead gefällt, und kann ich das aus dem Internet holen, kann ich auf der Webseite vom Potato-System als sozusagen Händler anmelden, kann dann den Dateinamen mit meiner Händler-ID erweitern und diese Datei dann weitergeben. Ich muss natürlich für diese eine Datei dann bezahlen. Und wenn die weiteren, wenn die das auch gut finden, und das aufkaufen wollen, krieg ich dann ein Prozentzahl als Provision abgedrückt. Also kann damit prinzipiell sogar ein bisschen Geld verdienen, vielleicht sogar meinen ursprünglichen Kaufpreis wieder rausholen. Ja, und das ist eigentlich prinzipiell gut für alle.
Und in welcher Größenordnung wäre denn der Preis für so ein Lead?
Das weiß ich nicht. Soweit ich weiß, war das noch komplett in Planung von Fraueninfrastruktur dabei. Ich hab nur eine Idee, die machen da glaube ich erste Feldtests.
Ja, ich hab dann mal nach gegoogelt, ich hab das auf paybest.de gefunden. Das scheint mir in der Tat zu sein, als kann man sich da schon anmelden. Auch wenn ich gestehen muss, dass ich jetzt noch... VfO-Unforderung. Ja, das ist natürlich ein spannendes Prinzip. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie machst denn du das jetzt? Also wir wollten ja jetzt so wissen, wie macht ihr das jetzt so gerade? Also taust du ja richtig Vinyl oder CDs oder was auch immer? Und lest du auch aus dem Netz Sachen runter? Lauter anständige Bürger. Vielleicht sollte der Moderator die Frage nochmal anders formulieren. Ich würde auch gerne das immer dir anrufen, die sagen...
Die sich dagegen sträuben. Momentan haben wir ja offensichtlich Leute am Telefon, denen es allen um Qualität geht. Oder warum bist du dann mit der MP3-Kopie nicht zufrieden, die du dir gezogen hast?
Ich mein, was soll man sich da komplett einziehen? Also ich mein, das sind ja zum Teil 24, 25 Lieder. Da muss man sich die alles so rechts suchen. Dann sind die zum Teil mit Störungen, wie er eben schon sagte, dass da irgendwelche Ruckla drin sind, dass das raus ist. Dann darf man sich das nicht nochmal ziehen.
Also ist dir zu viel Hesse auf guter Zeit.
Dann kann man besser bei e-Val gucken, wo sich günstig eine Platte besorgt hat.
Gut, aber bei so aktuellen Sachen, also ich meine, das sind ja dann doch schon mal 20 Euro, die so eine CD kostet, bis zu 20 Euro.
Na gut, die aktuellen Sachen interessieren mich größtenteils auch nicht von daher.
Philipp, dann danke dir für den Anruf und achte mal drauf, was mit dem Kartoffelsystem weiter passiert.
Vielleicht findet ihr ja noch die genaue Welle.
Ja, wir werden da was auf jeden Fall für den Chaosradio-Ticker, bzw. für die Webseiten irgendwie suchen.
Also wenn jemand das weiß, Berlin und Brandenburg, wenn jemand noch mehr über dieses Kartoffelsystem weiß oder über andere Systeme, die das Ganze managen sollen, dann ruft sofort an, 0373-9797-110. Dafür interessieren wir uns natürlich auch brennend. Ja, die Frage anders formulieren. Also Andy, da gebe ich doch einfach mal an dich, weil ich sehe gerade, dass du interessiert liest und dir diese Seite anguckst, aber wie wollen wir denn die Frage mal formulieren, dass auch Leute anrufen, die sich offensichtlich nicht drum scheren? Dass das Ganze...
Ja, also es ist ja im Moment so, dass es doch eine relative freie Verfügbarkeit von Musik im Netz sozusagen gibt. ja, die Frage ist, wie steht ihr dazu? Findet ihr, dass das eigentlich so weiterlaufen kann? Und dass die Künstler sozusagen genug dadurch verdienen, dass man sich im Zweifelsfall dann ja auch die CDs kaufen kann, wenn man eben gute Qualität für ein Konzert geht? Oder habt ihr sozusagen Verständnis dafür, dass die Musikindustrie das eigentlich komplett abdrehen will? Und seid ihr dann bereit, das zu machen, was die Musikindustrie gerne wollte? Nämlich, dass ihr für jeden Download bezahlt.
Also polemisieren wir das ganz normal in einer destillierten Frage. Findet ihr das okay, dass die Industrie so dermaßen abstresst, nur damit sie euch noch mehr Kohle aus der Tasche leiern kann? Oder findet ihr es gut, einfach drum rumzukommen und euch die Musik, die ihr sowieso nur zweimal hört, einmal runterzuladen? Und jut, 0371 77 97 110. Und am Telefon ist der Oliver. Hallo Oliver. Moin schon. Früh aufgestanden. Wie sieht es denn bei dir aus?
Also ich find runterladen ist Schwachsinn. Da könnten Viren drauf sein.
Ganz kurz, Oliver hast du Radio an?
Da könnten Viren drauf sein, möglich ist, wenn die billig sind. Und außerdem, manche Lieder dauern auch länger etwas runterzuladen. Das kostet wieder Internetkosten. Und das ist halt, wie gesagt, das kostet die Lieder kosten was und dann noch das Internet dazu noch. Und dann, wenn es wie gesagt Viren drauf sind oder noch länger dauert, ist es halt ein Abzocker, finde ich. Deshalb greife ich immer noch auf die schönen alten CDs drauf.
Ich glaube die Virengefahr beim Kauf von CDs, dass sozusagen der Verkäufer vielleicht eine Lungenentzündung hat, ist doch etwas größer als bei MP3-Dateien aus dem Internet. Aber ansonsten gebe ich dir natürlich recht, dass wenn man für die Lieder bezahlt, man ja auch nochmal fürs Internet bezahlt. Und für den Computer und eventuell für den Rohling und für die Telekom.
Und bei Kazaar mit deinen Daten, die du dann hinterlässt wegen der ganzen Spyware, die die mal mithalten kann.
Das geht ja darum, wenn du die wirklich kaufst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel bei so einem Service wie diesem Apple iTunes da Musik kaufst, dann kannst du ja auch sicher sein, dass die Viren frei ist, dass die Qualität in Ordnung ist und dass die Sachen auch zügig runtergeladen sind. Nur du hast ja trotzdem immer noch die Verbindungskosten. Du musst das Ganze irgendwie auf den Rohling brennen oder sowas. Oder auch nicht, auf die Festplatte legen. Das sind ja auch alles noch Kosten, die anfallen. Aber wie ist es, wenn du die Möglichkeit hättest, jetzt für so einen bezahlten Download zu machen? Wäre das für dich eine Alternative zur CD?
Ich würde einfach bei der CD bleiben. Ich finde es halt schön. Also so was auf dem Computer kann man zwar auch auf einer normalen CD brennen, aber trotzdem, CD finde ich halt gut. Also weiß ich auch nicht, wie ich das ständig von weg bekomme. Aber trotzdem, ich sag mal zum Beispiel Yahoo oder Lyrex.de. Da habe ich schon mal was versucht und das hat schon etwas länger gedauert.
Aber ich meine gut, das ist jetzt, ich meine gut, nein, ich würde sagen wir akzeptieren das, aber es ist ja subjektiv. Also das klingt ein bisschen so, als stehst du einfach drauf so ein Produkt zu kaufen. Oder ist das jetzt fies, wenn ich das so sage? Weil ich frage ja nur, weil ich meine natürlich kann ich in lang gehen und dann hab ich diese CD. Aber der Punkt ist ja der, dass ich meine früher haben die dann angefangen das E-Business zu nennen, wenn man irgendwie CDs bestellen konnte und dann kamen eben die Portokassen dazu und so fort. Und andere haben halt dann festgestellt, dass man ja auch die Bits übers Netz schicken kann. Und das ist ja qualitativ okay, nicht ganz dasselbe, aber doch. Geht ja schon in anständiger Qualität. Aber gut, du stehst halt eher auf der CD.
Hast du denn einen MP3-Player?
Nee, also so genau nicht. Wenn schon jemand das gerne haben möchte, auch wenn er unbedingt MP3 haben möchte und CD kann er sich doch verkaufen. Also nicht unbedingt gleich vom Computer runter. Ist vielleicht noch billiger. Also ich finde, der MP3 kostet nicht so viel. Und wenn man es zu Hause überspielen kann, kann man es halt machen. Es kostet dann halt nicht so viel. Wie extra auf eine MP3 als runter und sowas.
Nee, also ich frage, weil viele Leute haben ja auch irgendwie noch einen MP3-Player, damit sie CD's, die sie gekauft haben, auch unterwegs hören kann. Jetzt ist aber das Problem, dass gerade die neuesten CD's alle irgendwie so einen Kopierschutz haben, dass ich es gar nicht mehr als MP3 wandeln kann. Oder halt nur noch mit hohem Aufwand, sondern kann ich es natürlich einfach noch oder am bequemsten aus dem Netz runterladen. Dann habe ich es auch als MP3. Ich habe zwar irgendwie die CD gekauft, muss mir aber trotzdem noch mal die Arbeit machen, das irgendwie aus dem Netz runterzuladen.
Ja, das ist halt der Nachteil. Also Kosten, Kosten. Bei einer CD kostet gerade mal, bei einer CD kostet gerade mal eine normale CD 19, 95 Euro. Oder wenn es hochkommt 22, 23 bei Medimax.
Das ist aber schon übertrieben teuer, oder?
Also ich habe bei Medimax schon mal 22, 23 Euro gesehen.
Das war für eine Doppel-CD, oder?
So, und bei einer MP3, EGR schon gesagt, 25 oder irgendwie noch mehr Lieder drauf. Und dann dort halt trotzdem noch länger, als wenn man die kauft. Und dieser Preis ist dann halt schön vergleichbar. Der ist jetzt schon hoch, aus dem Internet und anderes halt. Der hat man halt gespart, finde ich.
Okay Oliver, danke dir für den Anruf. Ja, Konsum ist halt Konsum. Ich meine, da kannst du sagen, was du willst. Ob der eine das so konsumiert oder so, der haptische Aspekt ist zwar noch vorhanden bei einer CD, aber Konsum ist Konsum. Wir hatten jetzt zwei Beispiele, finde ich ganz okay. Der eine sagt, es ist komfortabel aus dem Netz, sich das runterzuladen, weil es schneller geht. Oder du kannst auch am Wochenende die Scheiße machen. Und er sagt halt, ich nehme mal nicht an, dass er jetzt so die Standleitung zur Verfügung hat, dass es ihm einfach zu lange dauert, dass es zusätzlich Geld kostet und im Endeffekt für ihn unkomfortabel ist. Ich glaube auch, dass viele Leute noch gar keinen mp3-fähigen Player haben.
Es geht mir darum, diese Möglichkeit, diese Kopie zu machen für einen mp3-Player, zunehmens eingeschränkt mit einer CD, was ja einfach ein klares Argument ist, gegen wirklich ganz ehrlich eine Original-CD zu kaufen, wenn ich damit nichts anfangen kann. Also wenn ich da nicht mal eine Kopie machen kann, wenn ich die auf einer Party mitnehmen will oder im Auto-CD-Player hören will, das ist ja einfach schon ein richtiger Nachteil bei einer Audio-CD im Moment, wenn ich die kaufe.
Die Frage ist auch, ob ich zum Beispiel eine neue Kopie davon kriege, wenn mir die kaputt geht. Weil ich habe ja die Rechte an der Musik erworben, dann schicke ich meine zerkratzte CD ein und dann müssen die mir eine neue stellen. Das wäre mal ein interessanter Versuch.
Kannst du mal probieren.
Ja genau, der ist zerkratzt und dann kriegst du nicht wieder an. 0371 77 97 110, die Nummer vom Chaosradio. Heute Abend geht es um unter anderem Musik und legale und illegale Downloadmöglichkeiten. Was ihr davon haltet, wenn ihr jetzt demnächst so einen Bezahldienst vor der Nase hättet. Würdet ihr den nutzen? Ja oder nein? Am Telefon ist der Felix. Hallo Felix.
Also ich wollte ganz am Anfang erst mal noch sagen, dass die CDs auf dem Computer nicht spielbar sind. Damit hatte ich jetzt noch keine Probleme.
Sprich mal ein bisschen lauter, sei so lieb.
Okay, ich habe mir jetzt neulich eine CD gekauft, wo auch drauf stand, dass die am Computer nicht spielbar ist. Und habe das aber erst später gesehen, als ich die dann schon auf dem Computer geladen hatte.
Das hat funktioniert.
Überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ja, das hängt wahrscheinlich dann doch auch von deinem Computer ab.
Und die war auch wirklich dann als CD da? Oder, ich glaube, das gibt ja irgendwie ein System, wurde die dann als so Windows-Media-Dateien, also praktisch sowas wie MP3s komprimierte Dateien, dann anhören kannst mit dem Media Player? Oder waren es die richtigen CD-Tracks, die du auch hattest? Aber als Audio-CD, also war die Qualität wirklich richtig gut? Ich weiß nicht, ich kann es wahrscheinlich auf dem Computermonitor oder Kopfhörer gar nicht so richtig beurteilen, aber... Also das ist halt so, dass da irgendwie noch so ein Datentrack abgelegt ist, wo dann die Sachen komprimiert nochmal drauf sind. Weißt du, auf welchen da zugegriffen wurde? Also weil ist das ja das Prinzip dabei, dass die Sachen auf dem Computer auch abspielbar sind.
War überhaupt keine Probleme, keine Umstände.
Aber lädst du dann auch Sachen aus dem Netz raus, ohne dir die CD zu kaufen?
Oh, also ich lad mich viel runter. Ich hab auch DSL und Standleitung und so.
Da geht das dann sozusagen.
Aber ich kaufe mir schon noch CDs. Weil so eine CD ist halt schon sehr viel schöner.
Tendenziell eher mehr als bevor es das Internet mit den Download-Möglichkeiten gab oder weniger?
Ähm, das kann ich jetzt so gar nicht sagen.
Frank Rosengard versucht schon wieder eine repräsentative Umfrage unterzubringen.
Nein, das ist ja genau immer das Argument der Plattenindustrie. Wenn die halt irgendwie am heulen sind, sagen sie, ja, das ist alles so schrecklich. Und irgendwie Umsatzzahlen gesunken und das böse Internet. Und dann gibt es halt die Gegenstudien, die sagen, naja, aber die Leute, die jetzt die Sachen aus dem Musik mal irgendwie tatsächlich zum Probehören laden, sagen, oh, ist ja prima. Oder diese Hemdschwelle einfach mal irgendwie was Unbekanntes mal runterzuladen, mal gucken, was es ist, was ich einfach so beim Suchen gefunden hab, wo ich jetzt gar nicht so drauf gekommen bin, denke, ah, das klingt aber spannend vom Titel her, das lade ich mir jetzt mal runter. Und das finde ich toll, dann gehe ich einen Laden und kaufe mir eine CD von. Und das ist halt das, was irgendwie auch die Gegenstudien eigentlich auch häufig belegen.
Also bei mir ist es oft so, dass die Musik, die ich runterlade, sind oft so Sachen, die ich so mir gar nicht kaufen würde, die ich zwar ganz nett finde und so, aber wo ich echt nicht bereit dafür wäre, zum einen 6 Euro oder 7 Euro für eine Maxi auszugeben. Also ich kaufe mir eh keine Maxis, weil ich die irgendwie nicht gut finde. Und das Album sich dann auch nicht immer lohnt.
Das heißt aber, wenn Musik dich überzeugt, dann wärst du auch bereit dafür, wenn du die online jetzt siehst, sie zu bezahlen.
Nee, das finde ich zum Beispiel auch schwach. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich nicht kapiere. Diese Dinger hier von Universal, die haben ja doch einige Kunden. Das kapiere ich irgendwie nicht, weil da 99 Cent schön Titel auszugeben, wenn ich es dann auch über Cava und sonst kriege.
Das Argument der Industrie ist ja, die haben ja so ein Stimmungsbild gemacht. Die haben mal gesagt, wenn das Internet es ermöglicht, dass die Leute eben frei sich Musik ziehen, dann können wir ja demnächst nicht mehr die Künstler bezahlen und dann wird keiner mehr Kunst machen, da wird das Abendland untergehen. Wir werden alle stotternde Analphabeten, die keine Musik mehr hören, weil keiner mehr sich das leisten kann. Also die malen da ganz düstere Bilder und das tun die natürlich auch ein bisschen in erster Linie deswegen, weil sie irgendwie, das gehört ja auch zum Geschäft, dass man klappert und dass man jammert, aber halt auch deswegen, weil sie natürlich der Meinung sind, mehr verdienen zu würden zumindest, wenn es eben diese kostenlose Download-Möglichkeit nicht gäbe. Und die Frage ist, hast du denn ein schlechtes Gewissen, wenn du so Sachen umsonst lätst, oder denkst du einfach, die Künstler, die kriegen das schon irgendwie hin, durch ihre CD-Verkäufe?
Also ich find auch, dass CD's teilweise echt viel zu teuer sind. Das ist dann natürlich schon auch irgendwie ein teufels Kreis, wenn die Industrie sagt, sie verdient zu wenig und muss die CD's dann teurer machen. Und dann die Kunden finden die CD's dann aber zu teuer und kaufen sie sich dann nicht und lernen sie stattdessen runter. Ich bin echt nicht bereit, für eine CD 18 Euro auszugeben. Oder also ich mach auch schon bei 17 Euro halt.
Gut, aber wenn du es downloadest, dann möglicherweise eine ganze CD auch für, keine Ahnung, 9 Euro kriegst oder noch weniger? 8 Euro? Wäre das kein Anreiz für dich?
Nö, also wenn ich eine CD sehe, die ich wirklich haben will, dann schaue ich halt auch in verschiedenen Läden. Neulich ist mir so gegangen, da habe ich eine CD von einer Band bei WOM gesehen, die hat dann irgendwie 17 Euro gekostet. Und dann war ich aber noch in einem anderen Laden, da habe ich die dann als Renewal für 12 Euro bekommen.
Ja klar, Preispolitik der Läden. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Frage, und das können wir im Rahmen dieser Sendung auch nochmal diskutieren, was für Möglichkeiten es überhaupt gibt, das Ganze über so einen Download-Dienst, der sich zum Beispiel die CD und das ganze Zeug spart, noch billiger zu machen. Geht das überhaupt? Und vor allen Dingen geht das auch in Deutschland. Ihr könnt mittalken, wollt ihr für Musikinhalte im Netz bezahlen, Chaosradio Nummer ist 031 77 97 1 1 0. Und wir verabschieden uns von Felix. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder? Dann 101, 5.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht kühlte es bei klam Himmel auf 11 bis 7 Grad ab. Morgen gibt es wieder viel Sonne, die Temperaturen steigen feiertagsmäßig auf maximal 27 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
In Berlin ist der erste kommunische Kirchentag geöffnet worden. Hunderttausende Menschen kamen zum Gottesdienst und zum Straßenfest unter den Linden. Morgen Abend wollen katholische Reformgruppen gegen das Verbot des Vatikans ein gemeinsames Abendmahl mit Protestanten feiern. Der Gottesdienst findet außerhalb des Kirchentagsprogramms in der Gethsemanik-Kirche in Prenzlauer Berg statt. Das Bundeskabinett hat die Gesundheitsreform gebilligt. Danach müssen Patienten ab kommendem Jahr mehr Zuzahlungen leisten. So soll das Krankengeld künftig von den Arbeitnehmern allein abgesichert werden. Die Union will die Reformpläne im Bundesrat zu Fall bringen. In Russland ist der erste SARS-Fall offiziell bestätigt worden. Der Patient befindet sich in einem Krankenhaus an der russisch-chinesischen Grenze. Auch in Deutschland gibt es wieder einen Verdachtsfall. Eine Frau aus Baden-Württemberg zeigt nach einer China-Reise Symptome der Lungenkrankheit. Zum Sport in der Champions League steht es zwischen Juventus Turin und dem AC Mailand. Kurz vor Schluss noch 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Moment. Ja, immer noch. Und das riecht ja förmlich nach Verlängerung. Der Fäcker wird zurzeit keine Aktuellmeldung. Gute Fahrt für euch.
Alle seine Konzerte sind total ausverkauft. Aber jetzt präsentiert Fritz Herbert Grönemeyer das Zusatzkonzert. Am 4. Juli live in der Wohlhalde Berlin.
Jörg Fritz, das Chaosradio kurz nach halb elf im Studio Frank-Rosengard, Andi Müller, Maguno, Max von Malocki. Thema heute Abend, Musik zunächst mal. Und zwar die ganze rechtliche Kiste, die da dran hängt. Momentan gibt es in Deutschland eine Diskussion ums Urheberrecht. Es soll eine Novelle geben. Und es gibt natürlich auch die Frage, wie soll das weitergehen mit der Musik? Weil die Musikfirmen beklagen Millionen Verluste. Das geht ihnen alles verloren bei den Tauschbörsen. Und die Frage ist, wie sind wir User drauf? Was möchten wir gerne haben? Und jetzt neuerdings gibt es, da hat sich alle sehr gefreut, die so ein bisschen Apple-freundlich unterwegs sind, eine Initiative von Apple, nämlich einen eigenen Musik-Download-Dienst, der offensichtlich funktioniert.
Genau, wir hatten ja vor einer, ich weiß gar nicht, so sechs Wochen ungefähr muss es gewesen sein, diesen sogenannten Digital Download Day, was also eine große Kampagne war, von der deutschen Musikindustrie Titel online anzubieten, Musiktitel online anzubieten zum Kauf. Und dann wurde auch mit einer recht großen Medienkampagne wurde darauf hingewiesen, dass es jetzt diesen Dienst gibt und die Leute sollen es doch mal bitte ausprobieren. Und irgendwie ist es dann aber ziemlich schnell wieder stumm geworden, weil es natürlich auch ein paar Haken hatte. Also zum ersten Mal das Problem war, es ging nur mit Windows. Und die Qualität war natürlich auch gar nicht CD-Qualität, die ich da hatte. Ich musste irgendwie viele persönliche Daten angeben. Und es ist alles so ein bisschen komisch und irgendwie, also mein Gefühl war irgendwie eher ein schlechtes dabei. Also ich persönlich hätte das vielleicht nicht genutzt. Dann gab es so ganz viele Gerüchte darüber, dass irgendwie über irgendwelche Übernahmen von Musikfirmen, Apple, Universal Music, das da war ein bisschen was im Gange. Und dann hat Apple eigentlich einen ziemlich großen Knaller gelandet, nämlich einen Musik-Online-Musikshop zusammen mit iTunes. Also iTunes ist praktisch der MP3-Player im Apple-Betriebssystem, der jetzt drinne ist. Und der hat eine automatische oder eingebaute Möglichkeit, einfach Sachen bequem online kaufen zu können. Und das war offensichtlich ein ganz, ganz großer Erfolg. Da ist auch irgendwie heute gerade im Spiegel online vielleicht noch ein Artikel dazu, könnt ihr auch mal lesen, wenn ihr da Lust habt. Da sind plötzlich alle, der ganze Markt ist überrascht und die haben dann eine kleine Revolution mit ausgelöst auf diesem Online-Musik-Download-Markt, weil die haben es einfach mal geschafft. Die haben irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was waren die Zahlen, max 400.000, 1.000.000?
Am ersten Wochenende, also sie haben mittlerweile 2 Millionen Titel vercheckt, aber es war so kurz unter der Million nach dem ersten Wochenende.
Also es war jedenfalls ein richtig großer Erfolg. Und jetzt rätseln natürlich alle, was haben die anders gemacht? Warum klappt es bei denen und bei uns nicht? Und es ist auch so eine Sache, die wir heute Abend vielleicht ein bisschen mit eurer Hilfe beraten wollen.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch diesen Digital-Download-Day aktiv miterlebt, weil ich wollte das ja auch testen und habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es irgendwie überlaufen war. Die gesagt haben, besuchen sie uns in den nächsten Tagen nochmal. Also quasi alle Unbequemlichkeiten, die man sich so vorstellen kann. Das Lustige war ja, dass beim Digital-Download-Day tatsächlich noch Geld verschenkt wurde. Die haben gesagt, ihr könnt euch im Wert von 5 Euro Songs herunterladen. Ab dann kostet es euch wirklich was. Aber ihr habt 5 Euro frei. Und das hat Apple zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht gemacht. Da haben die sich nicht für interessiert. Die haben einfach gesagt, kostet 99 Cent, kommt vorbei, wenn ihr möchtet. Und gut. Das kann man leider in Deutschland noch nicht probieren. Das muss man dazu sagen. Also alle, die jetzt Apple-User sind und es noch nicht wissen, man kann es hier noch nicht benutzen, weil es nur in USA geht und mit einer US-amerikanischen Kreditkartennummer. Das kann man hier leider noch nicht gebrauchen.
Aber die wollen.
Aber man will. Ja, man will. Was sagt ihr dazu? Würdet ihr das auch wollen? 033 177 97 110. Was haltet ihr von bezahlbaren Inhalten im Netz? Vornehmlich an dieser Stelle erstmal Musik. Würdet ihr für Musikstücke bezahlen? Der Preis, den Apple nennt, ist 99 Cent für ein so ein Musikstück und zwar für alle Musikstücke je 99 Cent. Ruft an beim Chaosradio. Auf Fritz und am Telefon ist der Robby. Hallo Robby. Robby, bist du noch da? Offensichtlich nicht.
Wobei das sind ja Dollarcent, ne? In Eurocent wären das gerade mal 80 oder so.
Im Moment.
Ja, wir hätten also richtig... Oh man, wenn wir denn Schnäppchen machen, dann sollen die sich erst recht mal beeilen. Reinhardt, hallo Reinhardt.
Ja, ich höre euch.
Wir haben jetzt das Radio leiser gestellt.
Wunderbar.
Ja, wir hören dich auch.
Zu Apple generell vermute ich mal, dass das noch eine Idee von dem Steven Jobs war, bei Apple das zu machen.
Richtig.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man die Historie bei Apple und die Vita von Steven Jobs kennt, ist wahrscheinlich Steven Jobs auch sehr beschränkt in den Möglichkeiten, die er jetzt hat. Steven Jobs ist jetzt nicht der, der vor Jahrzehnten mal war, kreativ und ungebunden.
Ja, aber warte mal ganz kurz. Wir wollen ja jetzt hier nicht über Steve Jobs reden, sondern über diese Musikbörse. Er hat ja mit dem iTunes angekündigt, es wird eine Windows-Version geben. Und das heißt, das worauf du möglicherweise am Spielst, nämlich dass Apple doch so ein gewisser Nischenbereich ist, das wird zumindest in dem Moment, wo das iTunes für Windows vorhanden ist und die eben auch diese Möglichkeit nutzen können, ist das Argument nicht mehr da.
Moment, das war nicht das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Nur zurück zu Steven Jobs.
Für erstmal aus, Reinhard.
Wenn man die Geschichte von Steven Jobs kennt, mit seinen technischen Möglichkeiten von seiner Firma, mit dem schwarzen Würfel, auch mit den Motorola-Prozessoren, war er besser als der übrige Markt. Und ich behaupte, dass Steven Jobs jetzt eingeschränkt oder beschränkt worden ist, von wem auch immer, weil er nicht mehr die Kapazitäten jetzt hat und an den Markt liegt, die er mal hatte, die Kreativität oder die Durchsetzung oder was er selber gemacht hat, vor längerer Zeit.
Ja, also Reinhard, ich muss dazu sagen, aus der Sicht eines jungen Users, also ich bin, du bist 47, ich bin 25. Ich bin auf jeden Fall Mitte 20, tatsächlich jetzt nicht im Kopf, wie alt ich bin, aber das ist auch egal, Alter ist relativ, aber in dem Fall nicht, weil ich zugeben muss, dass ich jetzt mein Leben, was noch relativ jung ist, verbracht habe erst mit PCs und dann jetzt kürzlich erst mit Apple angefangen habe, weil ich auch diese Begeisterung gespielt habe. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass das, was die da machen, finde ich, ist immer noch 200% mehr als das, was alle anderen machen. Also ich meine, vielleicht hast du noch geileres Bild vor Augen, das es früher mal war, aber für mich ist es trotzdem das Nonplusultra. Ich bin absolut begeistert davon, was sie momentan auf die Beine stellen.
Die Hardware-Schwierigkeiten von Apple, die sie jetzt haben, weil sie nicht mehr die Sachen selber fertigen, sondern extern fertigen lassen, wie gesagt nur am Rande, aber das ist nicht mein Thema. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist noch mal ein anderer Denkanstoß, dass durch die Globalisierung uns eine angelsächsische Denkweise und Kultur zwangsaufdoktoriert wird, die wir eigentlich von der historischen Entwicklung Eigentum gleich, ich kann, ich besitze das, ich bin Eigentümer und ich kann damit machen, was ich will. Ich muss nicht noch mal beim Hersteller nachfragen, ob ich das überhaupt verkaufen darf, das Programm oder kopieren darf, dass ich da noch mal darauf hinweisen will. Und wir sind hier in einer Verschärfung der Überwachungsmöglichkeiten von dem digitalen Ride-Management. Wenn man deutschsprachige Zeitschriften von einem Verlag, der Metall anfängt, weiterhin liest, das Thema ist seit einem halben oder dreiviertel Jahr kommt das immer wieder auf. Ich habe Bekannten, die leider die Zeitschrift nicht lesen und die sagen, Mensch, was erzählst du uns dann, wenn ich jetzt denen sage, Leute, kauft euch als Beispiel noch einen Computer bis Ende des Jahres, weil ihr nicht wisst, was hardware-mäßig an digitalem Ride-Management, an der hardware- und oder software-mäßigen Implementierung von der Überwachung dieses Bereiches mit am Markt ist. Ich bin gerne bereit, einen Preis dafür zu zahlen, wenn er angemessen ist und wenn ich nachher das machen kann. Denn laut der bestehenden Gesetzgebung oder was umgesetzt wird, ist die private Kopie wird außer Kraft gesetzt, die ich nach deutschem Recht machen kann, weil wenn der Kopierschutz eingesetzt wird und ich dann kein Kopierschutztool mehr einsetzen darf, um das zu umgehen, mache ich mich strafbar. Das ist die Aushebelung der privaten Sicherheitskopie, wenn man so will. Ich bin dagegen, das ist angelsächsische Denkweise und Amerikanismus am deutschen Markt oder hier in Europa.
Wie weit geht denn deiner Meinung nach so eine Privatkopie?
Die Privatkopie ist einmalig ohne irgendwelche Kopierschutzeinschränkungen von Seiten des Herstellers oder der Industrie.
Ich meine, wie viele private Kopien darfst du denn machen? Und wie weit ist denn bei dir privat sozusagen?
Moment, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, sind glaube ich bis zu sieben Kopien privat ohne kommerzielle Nutzung nach deutschem Recht machbar nach dem alten Recht. Ob sie noch nach dem deutschen Recht aktuell oder europäisch globalisiert im Recht machbar sind durch die DAM-Einführung, weiß ich nicht im Detail.
Da steht drin, dass man sozusagen so lange kopieren darf, solange man das von der, wie hieß das, legalen Dingster-Kopie, da gibt es diesen tollen Begriff, Entschuldigung.
Ja toll, was soll denn das, wenn ich einen Kopierschutz drauf habe und ich kopieren kann, dann ist doch die Sache, dass ich...
Naja, Moment, es gibt ja kein Recht darauf, dass du die Kopie machen kannst. Sondern das ist eine...
Es gibt ein Recht nach deutschem, also eine Möglichkeit nach deutschem alten Recht, dass ich Sicherheitskopien für den privaten Gebrauch sieben Stück oder so anschädigen kann. Altes deutsches Recht.
Ja, ne, das ist ein bisschen nicht ganz richtig.
Oder dass wir jetzt in juristischen Feinheiten verfeinhalten.
Das sind Feinheiten. Es gab eine Ausnahmeregelung vom Verbot. Allerdings ist das kein Recht. Weil ein Recht hieße, dass du einen Rechtsanspruch hast. Aber das ist ja zugegebenerweise Korintenkackerei. Also vom Grundsatz her hast du schlicht Recht. Das Problem ist sozusagen, dass man in Zukunft zwar eventuell eigentlich eine private Kopie machen darf, aber wenn es technisch verhindert ist, weil die Industrie das nicht will, und man dann etwas tut um diesen Schutzmechanismus umgehen, dann macht man sich strafbar.
Und das haut doch von vorne bis hinten nicht hin. Das ist doch total widersprüchlich.
Ja, Moment, aber versetze dich doch mal in die Lage der Industrie.
Oh, hätten wir dann viel Geld, oder?
Nee, also das ist echt der Rosengard, der kommt mit seinem Rechtspopulismus, das ist unglaublich.
Pass auf, ich bin Endverbraucher und ich hätte gerne eine uneingeschränkte Möglichkeit in Nutzung von technischen Möglichkeiten für mein Geld, weil ich bezahle.
Das ist richtig.
Und ich will keine Einschränkung meiner egal wie auch immer, ob es nun technische Möglichkeiten sind oder irgendwelche Art. Es kann nicht sein, dass ich mehrere Hundert oder mehrere Tausende für eine CD, also Musik-CD-ROM-Anlage ausgebe mit sechs oder sieben oder mehr kanalisch wie auch immer und kann nachher in ein oder zwei Jahren, je nachdem wenn was kommt, welche technischen Einschränkungen, die nicht mehr abspielen und bin dann genötig wieder eine neue technische Anlage kaufen zu müssen. Im Moment ist die Fertigung von Mainboards vielleicht ein Vierteljahr oder vielleicht ein Monat und dann kommt wieder ein neuer Produkt, ein neuer Schipsatz oder ein neuer Produktdreier auf dem Markt und ich habe dann keine Kompaktivität. Es ist seit mehreren Jahren ein Kampf, Treiber, fehlerfreie Treiber zu kriegen und die Treiber werden immer größer. Als Beispiel, ich habe einen Treiber für eine Grafikkarte auf eine Diskette gekriegt und bin jetzt schon bei einer CD mit Größen zwischen 20 bis 30 Megabyte, bei Druckern mit mehreren 100 Megabyte. Das kann es einfach nicht sein, weil ich dann wieder in der Schleife bin als Endverbraucher, neues Programm, Softwarebetriebssystem und neue Technik und das ist mein Geld.
Aber Reinhard, das hört sich, du machst jetzt einen Rundumschlag. Ich meine, das hört sich so ein bisschen an wie die Skepsis des alten Mannes der technischen Entwicklung gegenüber. Das Ding ist natürlich, sind das alles Punkte, aber wir reden heute Abend ja hauptsächlich über diese Legalität von Kopien, Legalität von Download und so weiter. Um nochmal auf die Frage zurückzukommen, würdest du das machen? Würdest du dir für 99 Cent so einen Song herunterladen wollen?
Wenn ich eine ungeschränkte Möglichkeit der Benutzung und Abspielbarkeit als Beispiel von der Anzahl der unangeschränkte Abspielmöglichkeit dieses eine Song habe, er ist in einer guten technischen Qualität und ich ihn mit meiner alten vorhandenen technischen Anlage abspielen kann, dann ja. Dann ja.
Also Interoperalität.
Aber das Problem sind auch die Leute, die jetzt nicht so vernünftig sind wie du und sagen, ok, ich mache halt nur meine irgendwie fünf oder vielleicht auch sieben Kopien für Freunde, sondern ich stelle das halt irgendwie ins Netz, irgendwie über Kasar, Idonkey, was auch immer und die Leute können sich jetzt dann runterladen.
Gut, in ganzem Sprung. Die Leute müssen sich doch überlegen, wenn Technik eingeführt wird als Kommunikation, wie ich die Technik brauche. Und wenn ich irgendwie eingeschränkt werde in meinen Möglichkeiten, ist das als Reaktion, die darauf folgt. Wenn ich eine Beschränkung der Kopiermöglichkeiten habe, dann ist das doch für mich eine verständliche Reaktion.
Naja, aber den CD-Kopierschutz gab es vorher schon. Quatsch, Entschuldigung, die Musiktauschbörsen gab es vor dem CD-Kopierschutz.
Also die Musikindustrie sagt ja, dass deren Kopierschutz eine Reaktion auf die Musikbörsen ist und nicht andersrum.
Ja, das ist übertragen die Diskussion, was war eher da, die Henne oder das Ei?
Nee, das ist hier eigentlich ganz klar.
Nein, es wird eine Leistung angeboten und ich will verdammt nochmal als Endnutzer für mein Geld eine Ware haben, mit der ich umgehen kann und nicht in irgendeiner Weise beschränkt werde.
Das ist richtig, aber ich glaube, das ist was weitergehendes. Zum Beispiel um ein Beispiel zu bringen, was mich sehr interessiert hat, was auch damit zu tun hat. Diese ganzen Urheberrechtskisten haben in den USA dafür gesorgt, dass man zum Beispiel Xboxen nicht mehr aufschrauben darf. Das ist so eine Sache, wo ich zum Beispiel auch sage, ey Leute, ich möchte, wenn ich was kaufe, möchte ich gerne diese Xbox aufschrauben können. Seid ihr eigentlich verrückt? Die sagen, man darf an diesem Produkt nicht mehr irgendwas machen. Ich habe von denen Technik gekauft, ich möchte damit gerne machen können, was ich will, auch wenn ich das Ding als Vogelhäuschen draußen an die Wand nagle. Nur, wenn du Musik nimmst und diese Musik in eine Tauschbörse stellst, dann trittst du ja sozusagen als Distributor in Erscheinung. Das heißt, du vertreibst dieses Ding und du trittst mit anderen Vertriebsstrukturen in Konkurrenz. Und das ist doch eine andere Kiste, oder nicht?
Wenn ich jetzt eine kreative Idee habe und Xbox als Vogelhäuschen draußen bei mir an der Wand nagle, dann ist das quasi eine Idee oder meine Kreativität, mein Urheberrecht, was ich mit einem vorhandenen Gegenstand mache.
Das geht aber um die Musik heute Abend.
Das war ja sozusagen nur die Gehhilfe gerade eben, weil das finde ich ja legitim. Aber ich finde es nicht legitim, unbedingt zu sagen, hey, da ist ein Künstler, der hat diese CD gemacht, die wird auf dem Wege vertrieben, wie das traditionell der Fall ist. Du bezahlst Geld dafür und machst dann aber Folgendes. Du stellst sie eben halt über Kanäle, die dieses Tauschen erlauben, auf eine Art und Weise den anderen Leuten zur Verfügung, die im Grunde das toppt, was so an traditionellen Vertriebswegen da ist. Weil es funktioniert besser als alles andere. Das ist ja die Angst, weswegen diese Musikindustrie so zittert, dass alle Leute sagen, hey, ich kriege es schneller, günstiger, billiger und im Grunde genau der gleichen Qualität über eine Tauschbörse. Das ist ja im Grunde ein Vertrieb. Oder nicht?
Ihr greift jetzt im Moment die Argumentation der Plattenindustrie auf, die immerhin noch gute Gewinne schreibt, obwohl es dafür meines Wissens nach keine genauen Angaben gibt. Und dieses Wehklagen für irgendwelche Hersteller, egal in welchem Bereich das ist, finde ich allmählich ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber willst du die Form enteignen?
Dann machen sich die Medien zum Handwerkzeug der Hersteller, der Phonoindustrie, der Filmindustrie, wessen auch immer.
Na, ich will mir den Schuh jetzt nicht ansparen. Reinhard, ich muss nur, ich will die Argumentation.
Und die Information hat frei zu sein. Uneingeschränkt verfügbar zu sein. Und dieser Ansatz sollte weiterhin gewahrt werden. Auch für die Musik, MP3-Files und was auch immer. Und ich wäre mich oder möchte das hier nochmal als Argument einbringen, dass damit eine Kommerzialisierung des Netzes stattfindet, die im Ursprung auch mit der Möglichkeit vom Militär her die Überwachung nicht sein darf. Die Reaktion dieser ganzen Tauschbörsen ist eine soziale Entwicklung als Gegenbewegung der Überwachung im Netz durch das Militär. Weil in Amerika war es militärischen Ursprungs, dass das Internet in den Hochschulen eingeführt worden ist.
Die Frage ist nur, was machen jetzt alte traditionelle Lieferstrukturen.
Ist es ein Fehler, dass die mit kommerziellen Strukturen da rein wollen? Ich glaube, wir können das jetzt erstmal so im Raum stehen lassen. Es gibt natürlich eine Argumentation der Musikindustrie, die interessanterweise von einer ganz anderen Prämisse ausgeht. Ich hab hier so ein Blatt Papier, das ist vom Deutschen Kulturrat. Das ist ein Ausdruck aus deren Stellungnahme zu diesem neuen Urheberrechtsgesetz. Die behaupten tatsächlich, Inhalte werden nur bei ausreichendem Urheber- und Leistungsschutzrecht angeboten. Das heißt, die gehen sozusagen so weit, dass sie sagen, der Kultursektor und der ganzen Breiten bla bla bla, Urheber und andere Rechthaber werden aber nur dann Inhalte in die digitalen Netze einspeisen, wenn sie einen wirtschaftlichen Ertrag daraus erzielen können. Ich hab das vorhin schon mal im Vorgespräch versucht mit Frank zu diskutieren und er sagte mir, die meinen das so und so und so, aber für mich ist das im Grunde genommen genau der Umkehr vor dem, was du sagst und was ich auch glaube. Nämlich das Netz hat ja gezeigt, man stellt da ein paar Computer ein und verbindet die miteinander und die Menschen tun sich gegenseitig einfach mal den Kram zu.
Im Grunde ist es...
Was sie sagen ist, das tut doch keiner, wenn er das nicht geschützt hat, wenn die Produkte nicht geschützt sind und wenn man nicht einen wirtschaftlichen Ertrag daraus erzählen kann.
Ich hab's jetzt aber auch das zweite Mal gehört und jetzt finde ich es ja auf eine andere Art und Weise blöd, was sie da geschrieben haben, weil du grundsätzlich, wenn du etwas publizierst, zumindest in Deutschland, du automatisch das Urheberrecht daran hast und du hast es nicht nur im digitalen Bereich, sondern du hast es überall, also automatisch auch im digitalen Bereich.
Sugar, das ist ja alles richtig. Das mag ja sein, dass du ein Urheberrecht hast, aber die Frage ist, ist der Grund, warum Leute etwas publizieren, warum sie Musik machen, ist sie, dass sie davon Geld haben wollen? Will ich wirklich Musik hören, die Leute nur machen, weil sie Geld haben wollen? Oder möchte ich gerne Musik hören, die Leute machen, weil sie Freude an der Musik haben?
Das Problem ist, dass aber die MP3-Diskussion häufig um so eine Musikstücke geht, wo es einfach nur rein um die kommerzielle Sache geht. Also wenn wir jetzt die Top 100 nehmen, da kann mir irgendwie, naja, vielleicht ein Dritter...
Das sind alles Huren, die machen die Musik nur wegen dem Geld auch kaum. Unterhalte ich mal mit Musikern, da gibt es wirklich eine Menge, die machen das wegen der Spaß an der Musik, freuen sich oder wundern sich...
Sagen wir natürlich alle, klar.
Ja, ich meine, das ist dabei ein paar irgendwie Leute, die eigentlich sowieso nur von den Musikleuten da so in die Studios gepackt werden und die Musik ist sowieso schon fertig, die brauchen nur noch einen Statisten, der sozusagen aufs Cover genagelt wird und das Produkt darstellt.
Rupstohlen, mitten in der musikalischen Unterlegung.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass... Ja, lüg es noch da rein, Reinhard. Wir hatten ja gesagt, wir wollten mal kurz dann in Torment so einschmeißen und dann weiter mit dir reden.
Mit der Kommerzialisierung des Internets ist es so, dass genau um die Thematik oder den Inhalt aufzugreifen, dass irgendwelche weltweiten Konzerne irgendwelche Rupstohlen engagieren und da noch Musik drauflegen. Und das sind die Boy- und Girl-Groups, die wir jetzt im Fernsehen haben, wobei ich keine Aussage zur Qualität der aktuellen Musik oder des Lärmens sagen möchte. So und es ist eine Sache gut. Man kann das Medium sowohl sozial, ich meine kostenverträglich oder kostenlos benutzen und einmal kommerzialisieren, um irgendwelche bezahlbaren Inhalte über das Netz zu vertreiben. Wenn alles in einem, na wie soll ich sagen, also wenn der Wert bezahlt wird, wenn es keinen Profit gemacht wird, sondern wenn es ein maßvoller Preis ist, dann habe ich auch über den Vertriebsweg, ob es nur Musikfiles, MP3-Files sind, wenn die technische Qualität gut ist, die ich mir an Einzelnen bezahlen kann, ohne Überwachung und so weiter, die ja immer mitläuft oder immer stärker mitläuft im Netz, dann finde ich das auch gut. Aber diese Auswirkungen, die jetzt mit ankommen, oder der Recht eines Konzerns, ich sag mal Kreativität, wenn Laien sich hinstellen und machen kostenlos Musik, weil ihnen das Musizieren selber Spaß macht, die auch selber dafür kein Geld nehmen würden, was soll es ja auch geben, es wird aber immer seltener, und dann Konzerne geben oder Zwischenhandel, der dann statt 30 Prozent 200 Prozent verdienen will, damit er den Aktionären seine Dividende von x Prozent pro Jahr weiterhin aufrechterhalten kann, dann ist da irgendwie ein Fehler im kapitalistischen System. Weil eine Steigerung geht nur bis zu einem gewissen Maß und dann ist einfach keine Luft mehr drin. Und das muss mal begriffen werden.
Ich meine, die Argumentation, die die Plattenfirmen momentan fahren, ist natürlich, wir haben solche Stars wie Madonna, die setzen unglaublich viel ab. Und wenn die jetzt aufgrund der Tatsache, dass es Stars sind und gerade solche Titel wie zum Beispiel von dieser Frau im Netz so viel runtergeladen werden und eben nicht mehr gekauft werden bei dieser populären Musik, dann geht uns Geld verloren, mit dem wir normalerweise die Bands finanzieren, die eben diese ganze Marge nicht leisten und bei denen im Grunde das Ganze überbezahlt ist. Das heißt, du bezahlst viel mehr Geld für Werbung und den ganzen Kram und für Covergestaltung und so weiter und das Management dahinter, als die Band wirklich bringt. Und dann sagen die immer davon, das wird alles bezahlt von denen, mit denen wir richtig viel Kohle machen. Und wenn das nicht passiert, dann fallen irgendwann die kleinen Künstler hinten runter. Das ist ja deren Argumentation.
Da möchte ich bitte die Zahlen oder die Prozentsangaben sehen. Schriftlich real. Wie auch immer. Von den Umsetzungen oder von den Gewinnen, die wirklich real an kleinere Bands oder Newcomer ausgeschüttet werden. Ich gehe davon aus, wenn ich als Autor mein erstes Buch veröffentlichen will, dann laufe ich Spießruten bei den Verlagen, weil keiner das Risiko schäut, einen neuen Verleger aufzulegen, der sich nachher nicht mehr verkauft. Und genau das haben wir im Moment. Es wird immer schlimmer.
Aber zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal hier Kollege Stephen King, hat mal versucht, eins seiner Bücher nur übers Internet zu vermarkten, wollte den großen Verlagen den Finger zeigen, hat gesagt, pass mal auf, ich mach das ganz alleine. Der hat es bis zum sechsten Kapitel geschafft, das war's. Dann hat er aufgehört, weil es sich nicht rentiert hat.
Moment, aber hat er nicht real noch dafür Geld gekriegt?
Ja, ja, der hat da Geld für verlangt. Also der hat es sozusagen im Eigenverlag gebracht.
Ja, aber er hat für das eine Buch doch ein paar Mark gekriegt oder ein paar Dollar.
Er hat es nicht zu Ende geschrieben. Er hat es nur bis zum sechsten Kapitel geschrieben, und dann hat er gesagt, es lohnt sich nicht.
Ja gut, aber liest du irgendwie so 800 Seiten Bücher am Bildschirm? Also macht das irgendein Mensch?
Nein, es ist genau das Problem, was auch in der Werbung jetzt stattfindet, mit den Suchmaschinen, dass Sponsored Links eingeführt werden, dass die Hersteller die erste Seite, wenn die Werbung auf der ersten Seite von der Suchmaschine ist, dass es bezahlt wird. Und ich kriege keine neutrale Information mehr durch Suchmaschinen. Wenn es weltweit nur noch drei große Suchmaschinen-Hersteller gibt, die von irgendeinem weltweit agierenden Konzern gekauft worden sind.
Wärst du denn bereit für die Suchmaschinen zu bezahlen? Mit einem Monats-Abo zum Beispiel? Weil, ich meine, irgendwie müssen das Geld ja herkommen. Das ist genau wie bei Gmbitze. Beschweren sich die Leute, da ist Werbung drin, aber natürlich irgendwo muss das Geld ja herkommen.
Ja, ich bin dafür bereit, Geld zu bezahlen, wenn ich eine angemessene Qualität kriege.
Na klar, also es geht darum, du kriegst ja ein werbefreies Angebot.
Moment. Generell muss ich aber erstmal das Geld haben, dass ich das bezahlen kann. Und im Moment ist die wirtschaftlich-finanzielle Lage so, dass immer weniger Leute Geld haben, um, ich sag mal ganz krass, außer ihren Existenzbedürfnissen Geld für irgendeine Sache bezahlen zu können. Und da müssten sich auch die Hersteller Gedanken machen, dass vielleicht eine DVD, die ich jetzt im Sonderangebot, der Inhalt des Films war sehr gut, für drei Euro gekriegt habe. Weil ich mich selber nicht für drei Euro hinstellen kann, von meiner bezahlten Zeit her, um angeblich, ich hab's noch nicht gemacht, um angeblich irgendwo was absaugen zu können, müsste mir das noch brennen und habe dafür die dementsprechende Qualität.
Das machen aber ganz viele Leute und das geht prima.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist nun deren Einstellung, die sie haben. Aber das ist auch eine Sache, die die Technik oder das Netz mit herbringt.
Das heißt also, die Hersteller müssten auch, und die Firmen, Musikfirmen, Plattenfirmen, aber auch die Urheber, die Komponisten müssen einfach damit leben, dass das gemacht wird.
Sie haben doch bisher gut gelebt. Ob ich nun in der Historie bei den Musikkassetten das selbe Problem hatte. Es ist jetzt nur mit einer neuen Technologie, aber das Problem des Kopierens ist derselbe.
Nein, es ist nicht. Weil du konntest einfach nicht eine Kassette in einen Kassettenrekorder tun und plötzlich war der Inhalt von der Kassette irgendwie 100.000 Mal in der Welt.
Nein, weltweit. Die Vervielfältigungen sind besser und stiller geworden.
Das ist klar. Sie sind identisch.
Im kleinen Bekanntenkreis konntest du von der Technik eine Musikkassette kopieren und konntest diese Kassette kopieren, natürlich wieder mit Qualitätsverlust, auch wenn du das mehrmals abgespielt hast.
Das ist richtig, aber wenn du deine CDs, heutigen CD, sind NP3s, alle nur im Bekanntenkreis an drei, vier Leute weitergeben würdest, das hätte die Industrie auch irgendwie nie geschrien, dann wäre das überhaupt kein Problem, dann wäre das ja alles kein Thema, dann würden wir hier nicht sitzen.
Naja, also das glaube ich jetzt kann man so pauschal nicht sagen, weil als Video-Recorder eingeführt worden haben, die auch den Untergang des Abendlandes prophezeit. Und bei der Audio-Kassette war es nicht anders historisch. Insofern, also man muss wirklich mal unterscheiden zwischen, natürlich gibt es technische Möglichkeiten, aber es gibt auch wirtschaftliche Realitäten und dann gibt es auch noch Blabla-Realitäten, wo man einfach mal gucken muss, ist es denn wirklich so, dass da jetzt wirklich die Verkaufszahlen der Musik-CD völlig abgebrochen sind, bloß weil es jetzt irgendwie Internet gibt.
Reinhard, dank dir erstmal. Wir haben eine ganze Weile gequatscht und wollen noch ein paar andere Leute zu Wort kommen. Lassen wir aber einen sehr, sehr deftiger und dicker Beitrag von dir. Gut, ihr könnt weiter anrufen. 031 77 97 110. Da haben wir jetzt schon mal eine Menge angeschnitten im Chaosradio heute Abend und wir haben es kurz nach 11.
Blue Moon.
Thema heute Abend, kann man jetzt ja etwas weiterfassen, wenn wir so möchten. Würdet ihr für Inhalte im Netz bezahlen? Im Studio sind Frank Rosengardt, Andy Müller-Magul und Max Formalocki und der Frank stellt das Thema nochmal so kurz vor und vielleicht, was wir so in der letzten Stunde so alles angeschnitten haben, damit ihr reinkommt, wenn ihr jetzt gerade erst angeschaltet habt.
Wir wollen uns heute beschäftigen mit Musik aus dem Netz, nämlich entweder legal runtergeladen von einem Online-Musikshop, wie zum Beispiel Apples iTunes oder irgendwelchen anderen Sachen, wie wasgibspopfiles.de oder holt euch die Sachen lieber ohne zu bezahlen von irgendwie Tauschbörsen wie Kazar, E-Donkey und was es noch alles gibt. Die sind in letzter Zeit ziemlich ins Kreuzfeuer der Musikindustrie geraten, weil die ihre Gewinne davon schwimmen sehen und versuchen jetzt auch auf die Regierung Druck zu machen, dass die ihre Gesetze entsprechend ändern, dass die ganzen Sachen stärker illegalisiert werden. Und diese Privatkopien, das heißt also, dass jeder für seinen Freunden ein paar Kopien machen kann von der CD, dass es weiter eingeschränkt wird. Und aber auch, dass diese Musikdownloads so eingeschränkt sind, dass sie dann zum Beispiel nur auf meinem Computer laufen, dass ich die dann nicht weiter im Netz verteilen kann.
Ich finde das ja, dass das eine lustige Perspektive ist, dass man sagt, man möchte, dass Sachen illegalisiert werden. Das ist eigentlich ein geiler Ausdruck, weil das bedeutet, dass ein bestimmter Vorgang fast schon zum Usus gehört. Und dann auf einmal illegalisierst du diesen Vorgang und dann darf er nicht mehr gemacht werden. Dann ist er auf einmal illegal. Aber er muss vorher illegalisiert werden.
Also im politischen Kontexten hatte man das doch früher kriminalisiert, oder?
Weil illegal ist sowas, was im Grunde von der Sache ausgeht, wenn man mal von der Wortbedeutung ausgeht. Und illegalisieren ist sowas wie von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge der Sache irgendein Label geben.
Das wird irgendwie gerne im Zusammenhang mit Drogen und Geschichten, Legalisierung von Hasch oder sowas, dann wird ja auch der illegalisierten Drogenkonsum, wo man einfach sagt, die Leute nehmen sowieso schon immer Drogen und jetzt plötzlich sind aber verboten. Das heißt also, das ist nicht von Hause aus illegal, sondern es wird halt illegalisiert durch die Politik oder wie auch immer. Illegal ist ja so ein Status Quo, das muss ja auch irgendjemand mal gesetzt haben.
Ja, und das wird jetzt vermehrt gemacht. Was haltet ihr davon? Findet ihr das okay, dass das so geschieht und dass sich jetzt alle überlegen, wie man euch verbieten kann, eure CDs zu rippen und weiterhin als MP3s zum Beispiel im Internet zu verbreiten oder eure Privatkopie mit euch herumzutragen? Oder sagt ihr, ich möchte ganz gerne auch so einen Musikdienst nutzen können und mir Musik runterladen können für Geld, wie zum Beispiel bei Apple 99 Cent, 0331 77 97 1 1 0, die Nummer vom Chaosradio heute Abend. Am Telefon ist der Stefan.
Ja.
Dein Beitrag zum Thema.
Na klar, und zwar über die eigentlichen Vorzüge von MP3s und einer allgemein komprimierter Musik, die sich übers Internet der Recht Problems verbreiten lässt. Und zwar denke ich, dass das prinzipielle Verbot von Privatgruppinen erstmal insofern wenig Sinn macht, als dass jeder User, der sich eine CD kauft, dadurch nicht prinzipiell unter Kontrolle steht, was er jetzt mit der CD macht. Also es kann ja keiner sehen, ob er die jetzt zu Hause rippt oder sonst was damit macht.
Nee, das ist richtig, aber die wollen das ja technisch zumindest verhindern. Und dazu kommt halt, dass es juristisch in Zukunft so ist, dass egal, was du nach Urheber gerecht theoretisch tun oder nicht tun darfst, wenn da ein Schutzmechanismus ist und du umgehst ihn oder hast irgendeinen Trick, dann machst du dich halt strafbar. Das ist sozusagen das, wie die sich das vorstellen.
Ja, Sache dabei ist ja auch, dass so viel Geld im Prinzip auch in dieser Entwicklung von den jeweiligen Kopierschutzmechanismen gesteckt wird, dass dadurch auch wieder der Preis für die CD steigt. Obwohl es sicherlich eine unwesentlichere Sicherung dieses Prinzip ist, weil man kann immer noch beispielsweise den Ton einfach abgreifen von der Anlage.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich meine, ursprünglich die Compact ist lustigerweise auch mal von der Firma Philips patentiert worden. Die hat alle diejenigen verklagt, die diesen Audiokopierschutz eingeführt haben. Die dürfen nicht mehr dieses CD-Logo tragen, weil es eben zum Feature einer CD gehört, dass man die kopieren kann. Philips ist da, weil die verkaufen jetzt auch die Brenner und so. Die sind da ziemlich offensiv geworden. Die haben auch alle ihre Beteiligung an Musikverlagen abgestoßen. Die versuchen gerade die Guten zu werden. Zumindest versuchen sie eben klar zu machen, dass es ein Feature von CDs ist, dass man sie eben kopieren kann. Weil sie mussten ja auch irgendwie ein Argument haben, uns das Vinyl auszureden, weil die ganzen anderen Argumente mit denen, das wird nicht kratzen, das wird überhaupt keine Störung mehr geben.
Sie argumentieren jetzt mit der Tonqualität. Sie sagen, dass durch den Kopierschutz der Hörgenuss beeinträchtigt wird.
Na ja, das ist ja sowieso bei MP3s der Hörgering für mich. Bei den normalen Qualitäten von 192 Hörer, das ist ja so gut wie gar nicht mehr hörbar, dieser Unterschied.
Aber das heißt, du nutzt sozusagen die Möglichkeiten, im Moment das unbezahlte zu liefern, schon zu sagen, darf ich so sagen, oder?
Ja, eher weniger. Was ich tue, ist, meine CDs, meistens noch vor dem ersten Hören, erst mal zu digitalisieren. Also als MP3s.
Und MP3s-klarisieren hab ich dir als Ausdruck zur Verfügung.
Alter Männer-Ausdruck schon, schon längst wieder weg.
Na gut, wie heißt denn das heutzutage? Eine Sicherungskopie machen, wa?
Ja, wenn man den...
Na egal, aber wärst du dann bereit dafür auch zu zahlen?
Na ich hab's jetzt auch nicht so mit dem Runterladen.
Ja, also das heißt, du tauchst dir CDs und...
Benutze ich dafür auch eher so ein Tauschbörsen. Aber das mit dem Bezahlen... Auf der einen Seite heißt es, es ist ein wahnsinniger Qualitätsverlust durch die Kopie. Aber offensichtlich genügt es doch noch, um davon downloadbare Exemplare ins Internet zu stellen. Also die dann auch mit einem gewissen Genuss hörbar sind. Allerdings, Preis ist auch eine Sache. 99 Cent, also 80 Euro Cent entspricht ja so bei 18 Tracks ungefähr einen normalen Preis von einer CD. Und in dem Falle kann man sich gern sowieso gleich im Laden kaufen, wenn man noch Wert legt auf Features wie Cover und Booklets und so weiter.
Na gut. Nehmen wir jetzt einfach für die Statistik auf und gucken mal, ob wir noch extremere Meinungen finden.
Vielen Dank für den Anruf. Wir werden gleich mal tief in unsere Schatzkiste greifen, hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz und ein Interview ausgraben, das wir vor der Sendung geführt haben. Und zwar mit einem angehenden Juristen, der sich, sagen wir es mal so, einem Jungen, dem Chaos Computer Club assoziierten Menschen, der sich juristisch mit dem Thema Urheberrecht auseinandergesetzt hat. Darf ich diese Formulierung so gebrauchen oder verklagst du mich dann? Gut, das alles gleich hier im Chaos Radio, bis dahin ein Momentchen Musik, damit wir das alles hier anwerfen können, so wie es sich gehört. Hier ist das Chaosradio auf Ritz, gleich viertel nach elf Thema. Heute Abend kopieren, downloaden, legal oder illegal, die Zukunft des Musikkaufens oder überspielens, runterspielens und vor allen Dingen auch die Zukunft der Privatkopie. Es gibt momentan, wir haben ja gedacht, das wäre eigentlich schon über den Tisch, aber es ist noch nicht beschlossene Sache, die neue Urheberrechtsnovelle in Deutschland, die sich an EU-Recht offensichtlich orientiert und dann eben halt hier in Deutschland auch eine Umsetzung erfahren muss und wo sich viele, viele Leute eine Verschärfung gewünscht haben und andere versucht haben dagegen zu halten. Wir haben wie gesagt ein kleines Interview zu dem Thema aufgezeichnet mit Julius, Chaos Computer Club Mitglied aus München, der sich juristisch mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat und ihn erstmal gefragt, was denn überhaupt mit der Privatkopie in Zukunft passieren wird.
Die Privatkopie, also sprich eine Schranke des Urheberrechts, ist nach wie vor ausdrücklich noch in diesem Entwurf des neuen Urheberrechts verankert. Daran ändert sich mal im Grunde eigentlich nichts. Lediglich wird es gerade noch in der Diskussion und das ist noch nicht so ganz ausgegoren, ob eine Privatkopie nur von rechtmäßigen Quellen aus möglich ist oder ob das eigentlich irrelevant ist. Ob man auch von illegalen Kopien sich eine rechtmäßige private Kopie ziehen darf.
Was heißt das in der Praxis?
Also in der Praxis würde das heißen, wenn ich jetzt eine MP3 habe, dürfte ich das bloß selber kopieren, wenn die Quelle dieses MP3s rechtmäßig ist.
Das heißt also, wenn ich zum Beispiel mir eine CD gekauft habe, davon einen MP3 gemacht habe, dann dürfte ich dieses MP3 auch einem Freund kopieren?
Beziehungsweise kommt es dann wieder darauf an, ob du bei dem Rippen dieses MP3s eine Schutzmaßnahme durchbrochen hast. Weil in dem Moment wäre es keine rechtmäßige Kopie mehr, aber das ist dann die zweite Frage. Bis jetzt ist es im Entwurf, den der Bundestag verabschiedet hat, steht drin, dass es nicht darauf ankommt, ob die Quelle rechtmäßig ist oder nicht rechtmäßig.
Was ja eigentlich nicht so im Sinne der Industrie ist, richtig?
Genau, und die hat eben massiv Lobbyarbeit betrieben beim Bundesrat. Und der fordert jetzt eben, dass es darauf ankommt, ob die Quelle rechtmäßig ist. Und der hat es letztendlich in Vermittlungsausschuss verwiesen. Das ist das Organ, was zwischen Bundesrat und Bundestag vermitteln soll. Der Bundesrat hat aber kein Widerspruchsrecht. Also der Bundestag kann einfach sagen, nee, wir wollen das aber so machen. Wir falten darauf, ob die Quelle rechtmäßig ist oder nicht rechtmäßig. Und ich denke mal, so wird es der Bundestag auch verabschieden.
Wie sind denn die Systeme zur Rechte Kontrolle im neuen Urheberrecht verankert?
Also da hat der Gesetzgeber hinten dran an das Gesetz noch eben so ein paar Paragrafen dran gebastelt, die eben von dem sogenannten Schutz technisch wirksamer Maßnahmen reden. Also das ist letztendlich DRM.
Was ist denn eine technische Maßnahme, also was ist eine wirksame technische Maßnahme?
Das steht nicht so richtig drin, also steht drin, eine technische Maßnahme ist eine Technologie, die dazu bestimmt ist, geschützte Werke, also zu verhindern, dass geschützte Werke kopiert werden können. Da sind wir natürlich jetzt genauso schlau wie vorher.
Das heißt also so ein Schutz ist nur dann wirksam, wenn er auch wirksam ist oder?
Das kommt jetzt darauf an, wie sich das entwickelt in der Rechtsprechung, in der Literatur, was darunter jetzt genau zu verstehen ist. Also man macht eigentlich selten, dass man in so einem Gesetz wirklich schon alles völlig im Detail regelt, weil dann kommt sofort irgendjemand anderes, der es ein bisschen anders macht und dann kann man das Gesetz, also das Gesetz ist dann nicht mehr wirksam. Und deshalb formuliert man das immer ein bisschen allgemeiner und wartet mal drauf, wie sich die Rechtsprechung und die Literatur und die Meinungen da irgendwie dazu entwickeln.
Das würde also heißen, dass jetzt ein System, was eigentlich in Wirklichkeit nur dazu dient, mich ein bisschen zu ärgern als User, dann möglicherweise gar keine technische Maßnahme ist und trotzdem legal umgangen werden könnte?
Also die Plattenindustrie wird sicher behaupten, dass ihr toller CD-Kopierschutz eine wirksame technische Maßnahme ist. Ich würde mir aber mal als Anwalt der Gegenseite, also bin ich nicht, aber wenn, würde ich mal schon mich auf den Standpunkt stellen, dass ein CD-Kopierschutz vielleicht das Abspielen verhindert, aber nicht das Kopieren.
Und wäre damit dann praktisch legal umgangen quasi?
Das muss dann letztendlich, müssen letztendlich die Gerichte entscheiden, wer da besser überzeugen kann und da würde ich mal sagen, lässt sich keine Prognose irgendwie wagen. Aber es bleibt spannend.
Ja, was wollte ich sagen? Also das heißt, mit irgendwelchen neuen Systemen, die sich die Industrierende einfern lässt, vielleicht auch gerade bei Musikdownload-Geschichten, dürfen dann möglicherweise die Gerichte zu tun haben.
Also wenn man einen Musikdownload hat mit Wasserzeichen, die sind hier auch wirklich explizit erwähnt, so Wasserzeichen und Verschlüsselung und sowas, da, also das wäre schon eine wirksame technische Maßnahme. Wirksam wird sicher nicht bedeuten, dass er unknackbar ist. Wirksam heißt, wenn man die vergleicht mit anderen Regelungen, wie zum Beispiel die Datenspionage, dass es eben einen gewissen Schutzgrad erreichen muss, dass es technisch, das heißt aber nicht, dass es technisch auch nicht durch einen Hacker oder sonst irgendwas überbrückbar ist. Also darauf kommt es nicht an. Sie sind glaube ich der Meinung, dass es erst eine Kombination verschiedener Maßnahmen zu ihren Tielen verhilft. Also zum Beispiel ist es sehr wirksam aus Sicht der Industrie, eine Webseite oder einen MP3-Server mit großem Tammtamm und auf Heise berichtet und alles Mögliche zu schließen, weil sie den Effekt festgestellt haben, wenn sie eine Webseite abmahnen oder schließen oder irgendwie traktieren, dass dann viele andere kleinere oder andere ähnliche Angebote von sich aus zumachen. Einfach weil die eben nicht Gefahr laufen wollen, selber da irgendwie Ärger zu bekommen und auch da in irgendwas hineingezogen zu werden, weil da stehen ja selten wirklich jetzt handfeste kommerzielle Interessen dahinter, sondern man macht es halt einfach. Soll ich noch mal ganz kurz was zum DRM sagen? Ja. Also ein ungelöstes Problem aus Sicht der Industrie ist natürlich das sogenannte analoge Loch. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein System habe, was mit super Watermarking und Kopierschutz und allem möglichen Tamtam ausgestattet ist, hindert es mich natürlich nicht, hinten an der Stereoanlage wieder meinen MPEG-Codierer anzuschließen und das wieder in einen MP3 umzuwandeln oder irgendwas ähnliches. Und in diesem Moment habe ich ja auch die technische Schutzmaßnahme nicht umgangen und habe in diesem Moment eine legale Privatkopie, die ich natürlich auch völlig legal mir willidig auf verschiedene Medien kopieren kann, mit meinen Freunden, nicht gewerblich natürlich irgendwie teilen kann. Und ja, dann so gesehen ist alles nicht so richtig schlimm.
Aber es ist ja schon dann auch ein Qualitätsverlust, so das wird aber dabei, dass man sagt, okay, das ist halt eine private Kopie und es ist halt nur eine private Kopie und die kann auch ein bisschen schlechter sein.
Da sind wir ja wieder eigentlich bei dem alten Gleichgewicht. Also es war ja bis vor kurzem so, dass man sagt, ja eine Privatkopie ist zulässig, weil eben man gewisse Qualitätsverluste in Kauf nimmt. Eben wenn ich es mir auf meine Musikkassette oder auf irgendwas überspiele, das kann ich beliebig oft machen. Und ich muss dafür halt eben gewisse Qualitätsverluste hinnehmen. Da war das Ganze im Gleichgewicht eigentlich. Also die Rechte des Urhebers und meine Privaten, die halt eben ihre Schranken finden in dem privaten Recht, eben Sachen frei für private Zwecke und kommerziell irgendwie zu vervielfältigen.
Glaubst du, dass sich auf EU-Ebene oder möglicherweise auch im weltweiten Interesse oder auf weltweiter Ebene da noch was tut am Urheberrecht, dass da möglicherweise entweder das in Richtung Industrieinteressen geht oder vielleicht auch wirklich dieses, ja weiß nicht, Verbreitung des Wissens und Kulturerbe, Musik, Archivierung, dass sich da aus der Richtung noch was tun könnte?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir in Deutschland amerikanische Verhältnisse kriegen, also dass wir hier auf lange Sicht die Wissenschaftsfreiheit oder ähnliche Sachen eben jetzt massiv eingeschränkt werden durch die CMA ähnliche Regelungswerke. Also die Gefahr besteht natürlich, aber akut sehe ich da offen gestanden nichts.
Frank Rosengard hat gesprochen mit Julius Chaos Computer Clubler aus München, der sich mit den juristischen Belangen des Urheberrechts und der Urheberrechtsnovelle, die in Deutschland ansteht und momentan bearbeitet wird, beschäftigt hat. Außerdem noch im Studio meine Person Max Formalotki und Andi Müller-Magun, der natürlich noch ein paar Wörtchen sagen möchte zu dem starken Tobak, der da gerade komprimiert in acht Minuten zu euch ins Ohr kam.
Ich will das eigentlich nur noch mal ergänzen durch eine kleine Anekdote. Julius hat ja auch erwähnt, dass die Industrie im Grunde um drauf setzt, dass die so abschreckende Beispiele setzen, dass die eben so Websites runterfahren oder eben diese Netzbörsen was auch immer halt strafbar erklären. Und ich hatte neulich mal das Vergnügen in einer Podcast-Situation, das in diesem Fall DVD-Branchenforums, mit einem Vertreter der GVU, der Gesellschaft zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsdelikten, dass ich das mal reinziehen will, www.gvu.de zu setzen. Und der hat also da die These vertreten, dass doch mindestens jeder dritte Internetbenutzer müsste eigentlich mal einen Tag im Gefängnis gesessen haben. Oder doch zumindest eine empfindliche Geldstrafe über 5000 Euro gezahlt haben für eben illegales Downloaden von Musik aus dem Internet, damit das endlich mal sich sozusagen rumspricht. Also damit da so eine abschreckende Wirkung erzählt wird. Der hat das ganz ernst gemeint. Ich meine, das war auch in München und der hatte auch so ein leicht, ja ich sag jetzt einfach mal faschistoiden Unterton, aber der meinte das wirklich ernst. Und also wenn ihr euch mal auf gvu.de das da reinzieht, da stehen dann auch so lustige Sätze, da hätten wir auch eine tolle Ankündigung für die Sendung draus machen können, wie ein Krebsgeschwür, nisten sich Wirtschaftskriminelle in den Wachstumsmärkten der Medienschaffenden ein. Wie begehrt er das Produkt beim Endverbraucher? Lässt du gefährdet, da sind die Umsätze der legalen Anbieter und so weiter und fort. Die Opfer der zurzeit organisierten Terminalität sind die Besteller der Branchen, Filme, Software, Musik. Alleine in Deutschland steht hier nicht ein Schaden in Milliardenhöhe. So geht es hier weiter und die sind wirklich holladio und falls jemand noch an polarisierenden Einblicken Interesse hat, möchte ich das wärmste empfehlen, sich mit den Jungs auseinanderzusetzen.
Savvy by Matrix, you are a virus, Mr. Anderson. So dass die Leute sich nur noch darüber ärgern, dass man überhaupt noch existiert. Ich warte ja darauf, dass der nächste Kopierschutz so weit geht, dass das steht, aus urheberrechtlichen Gründen können wir ihnen die Musik akustisch leider nicht zum Besten geben, weil sie sie ja nur hören würden.
Das ist denn wieder dieses analoge Loch, wo ihr jetzt von gesprochen habt.
Um dieses analoge Loch zu umgehen. Aber was haltet ihr davon? Also wenn ihr in Berlin und Brandenburg auch auf das gerade geführte Interview reagieren möchtet und an die Einsichten, die ihr da vielleicht gewonnen habt in Sachen Urheberrecht ruft an, 031 77 97 110. Ansonsten natürlich, wenn ihr dazu beizutragen habt, was haltet ihr von Musikkopieren und was haltet ihr davon, was die Industrie sich mittlerweile auch gegen alle anderen Arten von Urheberrechtsbrüchen einfallen lässt. Zum Beispiel, was mir neulich aufgefallen ist, wart ihr mittlerweile mal im Kino, Jungs? Habt ihr mal gesehen, die Vorspende, die jetzt jedes Mal laufen, vor jedem Film kommt ein Riesentext, wie auf diesen Videos und DVDs auch üblich. Es läuft, bevor überhaupt die Werbung losgeht, läuft ein Text durch, in dem schön drin steht, dass alle, die das abfilmen, dafür zuständig sind, dass diese DVDs so viel kosten und das seien nur die, die abfilmen. Und wenn man so einen sieht, dann soll man den anzeigen. Und hier ist die www.konstantin-film.com-antipiraterie. Da bitte vorbeisurfen.
Ja, aber das ist ja so eine düstere Anekdote. Ich finde ja die lustigen Anekdoten besser. Also ich hab nämlich neulich, ich wollte mir einen Matrix, ja, eben so eine abgefilmte Version angucken, erst mal bevor ich entscheide, wie ich ins Kino gehe. Und mir wurde also von der Version, die ich da gucken wollte, abgeraten, weil dem Typen irgendwie zweimal während des Films offenbar die Kamera von der Hand gefallen ist. Wo du dann irgendwie so rascheln hörst, schwarz siehst. Aber gut, ich meine, der neue Matrix lohnt sich auch nicht. Der ist wahrscheinlich einfach eingepennt, falls es keine Handlungen gibt. Aber okay, wir haben da noch einen Hörer in der Leitung.
Wir haben sogar mehrere in der Leitung. Und ihr seid ja heute Abend auch diejenigen, die sich hauptsächlich unterhalten sollen im Blue Moon. Deswegen halten wir jetzt erst mal die Klappe. Und der Timo ist dran. Hallo Timo. Guten Abend. Du machst selber Musik, ist das richtig? Und was hältst du von der ganzen Sache?
Deswegen wollte ich dir einen kleinen Tipp geben, weil mein Akku leider bald alle ist. Eine Seite namens... Vielleicht der Name ist nicht passend, aber auf der Seite www.graffiti- istmach.de kann man kostenlos runterladen, also legal. Da können wir welche runtergehen und finde es scheiße, dass... Also bei uns fließt kein Geldteil.
Also, ihr habt da Musik auf der Webseite zum Downloaden oder wie?
Schade, er ist nicht mehr dran. Da hätte ich jetzt gerne mehr von gehört. Das hat so eine entspannende Wirkung. Man merkt sofort, wie der Rücken locker wird. Dreck, Stark, äh. Gut, unabhängig davon interessieren wir uns natürlich auch dafür, was ihr zum Thema Musik sagt. Der Timo macht nun selber Musik. Man hat gehört, die Liedtexte sind noch nicht ganz so ausgereift. Aber vielleicht habt ihr ja noch Beiträge zum Thema. Am Telefon ist der Robby. Hallo Robby.
War ein super Abgang, ja. Ja, also ich würd die 99 Cent bezahlen.
Das müssen wir mal kurz erklären, weil das jetzt vor einer halben Stunde war. Das ist der Preis, den Apple jetzt verlangt für den großen Musikstore, was sie aufgezogen haben, im Internet sozusagen online runterladen, das Ganze. Und das ist der 0815 Preis für Musikstücke da.
Also ich würd das auf alle Fälle bezahlen. Warum? Ich hab mit Casa A wirklich sehr schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Beim Saugen hin und her, alles drum und dran. Und ja, wenn es legalisiert wird, alles drum und dran, würde ich wirklich das Geld hinlegen.
Würdest du das Geld hinlegen, weil es für dich dann bequemer wird? Oder weil du dann auch ein gutes Gefühl hast, dass vielleicht auch beim Musiker ein bisschen was ankommt, bei den Komponisten?
Ja gut, das sind, würde ich sagen, zwei Sachen, die damit spielen. Erstens würden die Musiker oder die Komponisten oder Künstler ihr Geld kriegen. Alles rum und dran, geh ich mal von aus. Und ja, ich hätte ein ruhiges Gewissen bei der ganzen Sache. Und gut, 99 Cent ist ein guter Preis für ein Musikstück.
Und da gibt es ja dann diese Einschränkung, dass du das nicht unbegrenzt kopieren kannst. Also bei diesem Apple ist es so, du musst irgendwie drei Rechner angeben, auf denen du diese Musik anhören willst. Also kannst du dann irgendwie auch nicht so beliebig einfach mal so irgendwie CDs davon brennen und die zum Beispiel im Autoradio hören.
Du kannst ein CD davon brennen?
Nicht direkt.
Nee, ich dachte schon. Nee, oder nicht? Also ich meine, das wäre die Erlaubnis dabei, sich ein CD davon zu brennen. Wie die dann verhindern, dass du die weiter kopierst, weiß ich nicht. Oder du kannst die CD nur auf deinem Computer anhören. Oder auf einem Medium, was keinen...
Im Moment sind die Beschränkungen noch technisch dermaßen mangelhaft, da man de facto damit fast machen kann, was man will. Aber in der Theorie ist es so, dass man auf drei verschiedenen Medien nur sich das brennen kann. Und dann ist Schicht. Entweder drei Computers auf einem iPod und auf einer CD. Aber dann soll halt Schicht sein. Allerdings die Frage, die ich noch mal an den Timo, als er, glaube ich, hätte...
Entschuldigung.
Wärst du auch bereit 99 Cent zu zahlen, wenn du das nur einmal hören kannst?
Nein. Garantiert nicht.
Ja, nur das ist jetzt aber auch sehr polemäßig. Also 99 Cent für einmal hören, ich bitte nicht.
Ja, na gut, aber so wollen die das ja in Zukunft haben.
Sagen wir 20 Cent für einmal hören?
Äh, auch nicht.
Zehn?
Das wär bei mir total der Blocker vor.
War nicht 5 Cent vielleicht nur ein kleiner Mikrobetrag so?
Nee. Also das würde bei mir so an der 2-Cent-Grenze irgendwo scheitern. Weil ich ihm wirklich auch ein bisschen beruflich mache. Nebenbei, äh, Diskotheken mäßig alles drum und dran. Und, äh, ja. Wenn ich schon Geld hinlege, dann möcht ich dann wirklich auch ein Musikstück haben, was ich dann für mich selber verwerten kann.
Aber ich mein, gut, als Diskotheken-Dingser zahlst du ja sowieso nochmal GEMA-Verschein, oder?
Ähm, das macht der Veranstalter.
Ja, genau.
Da steht in den GEMA-Bedingungen drin, der Veranstalter ist dafür zuständig.
Aber die GEMA wird übrigens bei uns zumindest erst mal, jetzt zumindest im Moment, schuld dran sein, dass es nicht für 99 Cent ohne weiteres angeboten werden kann, oder nicht für günstiger zumindest, weil da ja auch Abgaben zu zahlen sind. Also es ist so, dass für Musikdownloads gibt es natürlich auch GEMA-Gebühren, die müssen bezahlt werden, genauso wie wenn wir jetzt hier Musik spielen im Radio. Und da ist es so, dass, also ich hab mich da mal ein bisschen durchgeklickt durch die Seiten und wenn ich das alles richtig verstanden habe mit diesen ganzen Bedingungen, ist es so, dass also für Musikstücke ab fünf Minuten Länge allein ein Euro an die GEMA abzuführen sind.
Und wie ist das in den USA? Haben die gar keine Verwertungsgesellschaft?
Ich denke, da haben die halt nicht diese absoluten, diesen absoluten Anspruch der Verwertungsgesellschaften, sondern es ist so, dass die Verwerter oder die Verkäufer, die Händler, also quasi dann iTunes zum Beispiel, dass sie dann Direktverträge mit den Künstlern abschließen können.
Naja, das läuft teilweise in Amerika deswegen auch anders, dass es eben keine Verwertungsgesellschaften der Größe zumindest gibt, weil die nach amerikanischer Copyright können ja Künstler tatsächlich ihr Urheberrecht verkaufen. Also das heißt, die haben dann überhaupt keine Rechte mehr in ihrer Musik, sind sozusagen ausbezahlt und entsprechend bekommen sie auch nicht Pauschalen, wenn das irgendwo läuft, sondern das regelt dann sozusagen die Musikindustrie mit eigenen Mechanismen, wo aber die Künstler nichts mehr mit zu tun haben.
Aber was ist denn jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich bei Apple, wie heißt die Seite? applemusicstore.com oder so heißt diese neue Seite, beziehungsweise jetzt mit meinem iTunes-Dienst mich in deren amerikanischen Dienst einloggen kann und die erlauben mir in Amerika mit einer deutschen Kreditkarte zu bezahlen.
Das tun die ja nicht.
Was sollte die daran hinan? Würde die Regierung denen sagen, das geht so nicht, oder müsste man dann Importzoll bezahlen oder was?
Du meinst, welche Regierung jetzt? Die amerikanische oder die deutsche?
Die deutsche GEMA sagt, ihr dürft diese Seite nicht zugänglich machen für deutsche User. Welche Restriktionsmechanismen können da greifen?
Ich würde schon davon ausgehen, dass die da einigermaßen verspannt drauf reagieren würden und den einen oder anderen Dingensreiz kriegen würden. Ich sage jetzt mal solche Begriffe hier nicht im Radio.
Jokreis zum Beispiel.
Ja, Jokreis zum Beispiel. Also wenn ich deren Stellungnahmen richtig interpretiere, dann möchten sie das doch wirklich beschränken auf sozusagen autorisierte Verhandlungen mit den deutschen Musikverlegern. Das liegt ja auch daran, dass es zwar unabhängig von der Urheberrechtsdiskussion und den Gesetzen, gibt es ja auch noch Zivilrecht. Es gibt auch noch Verträge. Und zum Beispiel gibt es ja bei DVDs diese Region Codes. Die haben ja nichts damit zu tun, dass ich das nicht darf. Ich darf in Amerika eine DVD kaufen und kann die hier gucken, aber es ist zum Beispiel nicht erlaubt, amerikanische DVDs hier zu verkaufen. Und das liegt daran, dass eben keiner diese Lizenz bekommt, das hier zu verkaufen. Und genauso ist es mit der Musik auch, dass eben sozusagen die Verwertungsrechte immer für eine Region vergeben werden. Das heißt, sie wollen das auch gar nicht mehr, dass jemand hier CDs kauft oder da eben über jetzt Amerika irgendwie über Altions da kauft und dann sich hier sozusagen runterziehen kann.
Das heißt also, das ist Teil einfach der Lizenz, die die Musikfirmen aneinander geben, genau, dass sie es machen dürfen unter der Bedingung, dass sie es eben da nur in dem Land machen.
Ich bin mal gespannt zu sehen, ob Apple hier irgendwie ein Extra-Deal hinkriegen wird für die deutsche Version von Altions. Robbie, dank dir erstmal für deinen Anruf.
Wenn Fritz in Stausberg, dann 102, 6.
Holla, 23.34. Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht kühlt es ein bisschen ab bei Klabenhimmel auf 11 bis 7 Grad. Morgen gibt es wieder viel Sonne, die Temperaturen steigen auf maximal 27 Grad. Die Meldung wird Gerald Kötter einrichten.
Der AC Mailand ist Europas neuer Fußball-Champion. Im italienischen Champions League Finale gegen Juventus Turin gewannen die Mailander mit 3 zu 2 im Elfmeterschießen. Im Old Trafford Stadion in Manchester war die Partie bis nach der Fellingerung torlos geblieben. Der erste ökumenische Kirchentag hat am Abend in Berlin begonnen. Zum Gottesdienst vor dem Brandenburger Tor kamen 140.000 Menschen. Zu den Teilnehmern sprachen auch Bundespräsident Rao und Bundeskanzler Schröder. Bis Sonntag werden 200.000 Besucher auf dem Kirchentag erwartet. Als Konsequenz aus den jüngsten schweren Busunfällen will die Bundesregierung die Sicherheitsbestimmungen deutlich verschärfen. Verkehrsminister Stolpe kündigte heute in Berlin an, Manipulationen an Fahrtenschreibern und Tempobegrenzern künftig strafrechtlich zu verfolgen. Verstöße gegen vorgeschriebene Ruhezeiten und Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen sollen mit erhöhten Bußgeldern geahndet werden. Die Vereinten Nationen wollen 1.000 Soldaten nach Kongo schicken. Die Eingreiftruppe unter französischem Kommando soll das Blutvergießen im Nordosten des zentralafrikanischen Landes unterbinden. Das Mandat soll am Freitag vom Welt-Sicherheitsrat verabschiedet werden. Defekter Fritz zurzeit keine aktuellen Meldungen.
Gutes Fahrt für euch.
Er sitzt auf einem riesen Haufen. Konzertkarten für Metallica, Herbert Grönemeyer und Virginia Jetzt. Sein Name, Metallibert Jetzt. Sein Beruf, Fritz Kartenzwerg. Sein Auftrag, Metallibert Jetzt rufen. Der nächste Woche ist auf Fritz, die Fritz Kartenzwergwoche.
Mit Konzertkarten, die ihr nicht kaufen könnt, aber gewinnen.
Und immer, wenn Metallibert Jetzt ruft, gibt's unkäufliche Karten für Virginia Jetzt und Miles. Am Montag live in den Fritz Studios. Oder Herbert Grönemeyer live in der Waldbühne Berlin. Oder Metallica live in der Wohlheide Berlin. Die Fritz Kartenzwergwoche. Hört ihr? Metallibert Jetzt ruft an und gewinnt die unkäuflichen Konzertkarten ab Montag.
Das Chaosradio, Nummer 81, 82, Musik aus dem Netz, demnächst nur noch legal oder bezahlt. Wir diskutieren hier sozusagen ein bisschen um die Fragestellung, wie das eigentlich in Zukunft funktioniert, dass A Künstler Kunst machen können und B sie davon noch irgendwie sich vielleicht auch finanzieren können und C wie sich das damit verträgt, dass das Internet nun mal ermöglicht, dass man nun mal frei Sachen austauschen kann, zum Beispiel eben Musik in Form von digitalen Dateien. Die Musikindustrie sagt grob, wenn überall an den Bäumen Äpfeln wachsen, dann kann man nicht mehr mit Äpfeln handeln. Also weg mit den Apfelbäumen und dann müssen wir das alles noch ein paar Zäune aufstellen und dann gibt es da diese Bezahltasten und diese Münzeinwurfschlitze und so ungefähr stellen die sich das vor. Also weg mit den Musikbörsen, es darf eigentlich keine freien Austauschmöglichkeiten geben, sondern es muss die Durchsetzung der Eigentumsrechte, eben der Erwerb von Nutzungsrechten sozusagen, da einzutun. Und die Frage, die wir euch stellen wollen ist eben, findet ihr das irgendwie in Ordnung? Oder wie stellt ihr euch das vor? Oder gibt es vielleicht noch andere Ideen, wie man Künstler in Zukunft finanzieren könnte? Also freier Austausch oder Kapitalismus?
Um nochmal, weil wir jetzt gerade, das muss man dazu sagen, liebe Chaos-Radio-Hörer auf RITS schon heiß diskutiert haben, bevor wir überhaupt in diese kleine Präsentationsphase gegangen sind, worum es überhaupt geht und welche Frage wir stellen sollen. Wenn ich das also richtig verstehe, gehen die davon aus, dass du erstmal per se überhaupt keine Rechte an irgendwas hast, sondern du erkaufst dir sozusagen dein kurzzeitiges Nutzungsrecht oder dein Eigentumsrecht für eine bestimmte Sache, oder wie?
Nee, es ist ja noch viel schlimmer. Also die stellen sich das so vor, dass ein Künstler, der Kunst macht, ist halt der irgendeine Musik produziert, dass der halt daran ein Eigentumsrecht hat und entsprechend über sein Eigentum bestimmt. So wie du halt über dein Haus oder deine Wohnung bestimmt, wer da reingeht, bestimmt der dann halt was mit seiner Musik passiert. Und die sprechen sozusagen jedem, der sagt, ja, aber ich habe gar keine Kohle und ich möchte Musik auch hören. Die sprechen dir einfach das Recht ab, sondern die sagen derjenige, der es gemacht hat, bestimmt darüber. Und zwar auf ewig Armen. Und wir sagen ja eigentlich... Ja, ich meine, ich wollte ja eigentlich, dass der mich endlich mal lobt, dass ich eben nicht die Frage formuliert habe als Sozialismus oder Barbarei, weil dann wären wir irgendwie glaube ich bei einer anderen Diskussion. Aber hatten wir nicht eine Hörerin in der Leiter, die uns von dieser Frage abbringen wollte?
Ja, wir bringen jetzt einfach Andi von seiner Argumentation ab. Hier im Studio übrigens Andi Müller-Magun, Frank Rosengard und mein Person Max von Malott. Hier am Telefon ist die Antje. Hallo Antje. Antje, hilf uns, hilfst du uns doch mal aus der Brittulier aus.
Ja, ich wollte zum einen noch was sagen zu diesem Apple Music Star. Und zwar, ihr hattet doch gemeint, ob man sich das auf CD brennen kann. Man kann sich das auf beliebig viele CDs brennen.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, ja.
Allerdings ist eine Sperre eingebaut, dass man das nur so automatisieren kann, dass man maximal zehn automatisiert brennen kann. Und dann muss man quasi von Hand nochmal neu einstellen, was man eigentlich brennen möchte. Des Weiteren kann man sich das auf beliebig viele iPods, also auf MP3-Spieler kopieren. Wenn man 100 hat, dann theoretisch auf 100. Nur so viele MP3-Spieler hat ja niemand. Und theoretisch gibt es eine Kopiersperre zurück vom iPod auf Computer. Das ist nur theoretisch, also mit Terminal, also mit Shell-Befehl kann man das von Hand machen. Und man kann es auf maximal drei Computern gleichzeitig laufen lassen.
Genau, das war das mit den drei Dingern, ja?
Genau. Und im lokalen Netz auf maximal fünf Rechnern, soviel ich weiß. Da bin ich nur mit der Zahl nicht sicher. Also es ist alles ziemlich uneingeschränkt eigentlich.
Weißt du, wie die das realisieren mit dieser Einschränkung der Computerzahl, auf denen das abgespielt werden kann?
Es ist ein Wasserzeichen. Und schon DRM, also Digital Rights Management. Und mit dem Wasserzeichen ermöglicht es dir abzugleichen, welche Titel du bereits gekauft hast bei dem Apple Music Star. Und du musst online gehen und einen bestimmten Rechner freischalten quasi. Der ist dann freigeschaltet, diese Musik zu hören. Und wenn dann, was weiß ich, dein Haus abbrennt und der Rechner keine Musik mehr hören kann, dann geht es halt wieder online mit deinem nächsten Rechner und sagst, nee, der alte Rechner jetzt nimm mal der hier jetzt, bitte.
Das Wasserzeichen macht das aber auch möglich, dass wenn diese Sachen dann im Internet kursieren, damit dann auf mich zurückgeschlossen wird.
Theoretisch schon, aber es geht ja nur auf maximal drei Rechner zu spielen. Und du kannst auch nur von maximal drei Rechnern aus brennen.
Wieso, wie realisieren die das? Wissen die, woher der dritte Rechner, dass er der letzte Rechner ist, auf dem es gespielt werden darf?
Nur immer maximal drei gleichzeitig dürfen angemeldet sein quasi.
Also registriert sein. Ja, das ist über die Netzwerkkarten, also ich glaube die Nebemack-Adressen oder so was.
Und wie ist das, dieses CD-Brennen, das kannst du denn aber nur direkt aus dem Programm ausraus machen? Du kannst jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ich kopiere das jetzt zum Beispiel auf dem PC rüber und brenne es da auf CD.
Es geht nur von iTunes aus im Moment. Weil das Format ist kein MP3, sondern ARC, das ist also eine etwas stärkere Konfirmierung, wenn ich das recht verstanden habe. Also 128 bei ARC, entsprechend 196 bis bei MP3. Das heißt, dieses Format ist im Moment zumindest auf dem Archintosh nur in iTunes abspielbar. Aber das dürfte dann auch für die Windows-Itunes-Version gelten.
Also das ARC ist ein Audioformat, was irgendwie im MP4-Standard gerade verwendet wird, aber sie verwenden halt einen Zusatz dafür, nämlich ein Verschlüsselungsfeature. Das heißt also, die Sachen sind da irgendwie genau. Also das Wasserzeichen ist ja die eine Sache und die Verschlüsselung ist die andere Sache. Also das Wasserzeichen soll ja im Prinzip nur, wie bei auch den Geldscheinen das Wasserzeichen ist, nachher, wenn diese Sachen im Umlauf sind oder irgendwo sind, dann nachvollzogen werden können, wo die herkommen. Das ist der eigentliche Sinn beim Wasserzeichen.
Bei Geldscheinen sind aber keine Seriennummern, die sind da extra drauf.
Im digitalen Sinne, bei Bildern macht man das, um zum Beispiel zu schauen, wo die Sachen herkommen. Auch diese Online-Dienste wie Popfiles, die machen das zum Beispiel auch so. Das steht auch so ein bisschen verklausuliert in ihren Geschäftsbedingungen drin, dass sie sich auch das Recht vorbehalten, deine persönlichen Daten, die du bei der Anmeldung angegeben hast, möglicherweise an Firmen oder an Gesellschaften weiterzugeben, die sich irgendwie mit der Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverschlüssen beschäftigen und die dann natürlich anhand dieses Wasserzeichens, was speziell für dich in dieses Lied reinkopiert worden ist, dann auch gucken können, wer denn die Sachen weitergegeben hat illegal.
Ja, es ist ja witzlos, das weiterzugeben, weil die anderen Leute können ihren Computer ja gar nicht bei Apple, in dem Apple Store dann zum Anhören quasi anmelden.
Genau, du glaubst aber damit schon, dass das System auch soweit sicher ist.
Ja, es muss ja insofern sicher sein, sonst hätten ja die größten Musikkonzerne nicht Zugstätten.
Aber Sekunde mal an, hier heißt das, man muss tatsächlich angemeldet sein bei Music Store, wenn man sich seine Musik anhören will, in der Sekunde muss man online angemeldet sein?
Nee, nee, nee, man muss es einmal anmelden, dann ist es gleich geschaltet, dann kann man wieder offline gehen.
Ah, okay, alles klar.
Also ist es so, dass die, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, diese Musikstücke, wenn du die bestellst, kaufst, werden die speziell für dich angepasst, also entsprechend für dich verschlüsselt. Also du musst praktisch an deinem Rechner sagen, gib mir jetzt irgendwie so einen Teil des Schlüssels, gib mir jetzt einen Code, der rechnet wird aus meiner Hardware, die ich hab, die wird dann an Apple geschickt. Apple nimmt dann diesen Code, verschlüsselt, da eingebaut, dann diese Musik mit und schickt sie mir dann zurück. Und mein Programm, mein Eintunes sieht dann, ah, okay, hier ist irgendwie der richtige Schlüssel dazu. Ich bin sozusagen der Rechner, von dem es quasi beantragt wurde und ich kann es jetzt auch abspielen und entschlüsseln.
Der Vorteil gegenüber irgendwelcher, gegenüber Hardware Digital Rights Management ist, dass es nicht an den Computer gebunden ist. Also ich kann es in zehn Jahren mit den Computern, die ich dann hab, theoretisch immer noch anhören.
Aber mal ein kurzer Trick. Also ich glaube, ich habe jetzt verstanden, wie das funktioniert. Das heißt, ich gebe dann mein iditis, mein gewasserzeichnetes Musikstück an einen Kumpel. Dann muss der Kumpel zumindest einmal beim Apple Store gewesen sein, um sich selber eben halt anzumelden mit einem bestimmten Zeichen und der muss dann mit Apple abgleichen, dass er sich dieses Ding jetzt anhören kann. Und dann sagt Apple, okay, der hat sich gemeldet, der darf das hören. Damit ist bei dir auf der Liste ein Strich gemacht und es dürfen insgesamt nur noch zwei Leute sich anmelden.
Genau.
So funktioniert das ja im Grunde. Aber was ist dann, wenn ich dann sage, okay, ich habe mir ganz viele Musikstücke runtergeladen, sage, mein Rechner ist abgebrannt und gehe mit dem Rechner, mit dem ich gesagt habe, ich habe das gemacht, nie mehr ins Internet und dann mit einem neuen, dann könnte man das ja im Grunde umgehen, ne? Ja, aber das ist natürlich sehr kompliziert.
Naja, ich meine, es setzt natürlich voraus, dass es eine Art zentrale Rechteverwaltung gibt, was natürlich auch keine sehr schöne Sache ist, aber es ist immerhin so gelöst, dass es für den Benutzer keine große Einschränkung gibt, im Gegensatz zu sonstigen Kopierschutzen.
Die können natürlich schon Netzwerke aufmachen, damit sie wissen, wer deine Kumpels sind, die haben dich registriert, die können dich mit dir assoziieren, das ist schon relativ gut möglich, im Prinzip das Networking, da wissen die, wer zu dir gehört.
Wenn ich einem Freund was weitergeben möchte, und der möchte das quasi unter meinem Namen registrieren, dann muss ich aber in dem Freund auch genug Vertrauen haben, dass der mal kurz mein Passwort verwenden darf. Das heißt, die wissen gar nicht, dass es der ist, sondern es ist dann mein Computer.
Ah, das ist natürlich clever, okay. Woher hast du schon so viel Erfahrung? Damit hast du selber schon mal viel runtergeladen, oder?
Nee, ich hab meine amerikanischen Verwandten noch nicht überzeugen können, dass ich unbedingt das Ganze ausprobieren muss. Aber man kann natürlich von Deutschland aus auch Pro behören. Man kann iTunes natürlich verwenden, man kann diesen Apple News Extra verwenden. Man kann nur nicht bestellen, weil man keine amerikanische Kreditkartennummer hat. Man kann die Titelprobe hören und sich anschauen, was es alles gibt. Und es scheint alles recht bequem zu sein. Da hab ich mir natürlich auch angeschaut, was sind die genauen Bestimmungen dafür.
Und ist es für dich denn jetzt eine wirkliche Alternative?
Auf jeden Fall. Vor allem ist es ja nicht mal so teuer, wie es sich anhört. Also 99 Cent pro Titel sind teuer, wenn 20 Stücke auf der Platte sind. Aber nein, eine ganze CD kostet 99 oder 9, 99.
Aber du hast ja schon gehört, dass bei uns zumindest im Moment die GEMA da irgendwie noch mitspielt. Das heißt also, bei uns sind wahrscheinlich andere Preise realistisch.
Ist klar, bei uns dürften das im Moment ziemlich düster aussehen. Aber es gibt, mal davon abzusehen, dass es sehr bequem ist, auch mit Suchfunktionen und so. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Punkte, die wirklich für so ein System sprechen würden. Und zwar, so wie die Dinge im Moment ausschauen mit CDs, ist es ja so, dass man nur noch relativ schwer die CDs überhaupt vollständig verwenden kann. Man kann nur noch relativ schwer MP3s zum Beispiel kopieren, für einen MP3-Spieler, wegen Kopierschutz. Man kann nur noch relativ schwer sich irgendwelche CDs brennen, wenn man zum Beispiel im Auto-Radio hören möchte oder so, mit einem Auto-CD-Spieler. Das heißt, es spricht im Moment doch einiges dafür, dass es ein etwas lockereres System gibt.
Aber das ist ja für mich erstmal kein Argument für Apple iTunes oder für so einen Online-Musicstore, sondern für ein Download aus dem Internet eigentlich, weil das ist ja noch ein bisschen bequemer.
Ja, bloß, erstens bis man da was findet, dann ist die Qualität häufig extrem schlecht, also 24 bit oder sowas, dann bricht der Download zusammen oder dauert unglaublich lange. Also das ist alles richtig unbequem.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass das Angebot von Apple, also ich hab da auch mal reingeguckt, hat mich persönlich jetzt auch nicht so umgehauen. Also ich finde halt irgendwie die Sachen, die ich jetzt speziell mal suche, irgendwelche wirklich ganz abgefahrenen Sachen, natürlich nur auf Tauschbörsen und weder irgendwie bei Amazon noch möglicherweise irgendwie im Plattenladen.
Ich glaube im Moment ist das bei Apple wirklich der amerikanische Markt, der da abgedeckt wird.
Die haben irgendwie 200.000 Titel oder so, mehr ist es nicht, ne?
Ja, da ist inzwischen noch einiges dazugekommen. Wir sind halt wirklich so die fünf Majors, die da anbieten, ne?
Es ist auch alles noch so ein bisschen unausgereift. Ich hatte mir das mal angeschaut und hatte mal geguckt, dachte mir, ja bist du mal gespannt, was es so in Reggae-Richtung gibt. Und dann gibt es irgendwie World Music, aber Reggae gibt es nicht. Dann gehst du auf World Music, gehst auf einen Musiker und stellst fest, dass hier oben, wo die die Verzeichnisse eingeben, es steht immer Home, Sohn zur Musikrichtung und dann noch ein Unterverzeichnis und dann der Musiker und dann stand da halt tatsächlich Home, Reggae und der Musiker. Und ich dachte, gibt es den also doch. Also hab ich wieder gesucht und hab's aber nicht gefunden und die entscheiden sich momentan offensichtlich noch, was für Bereiche sie so anbieten. Aber trotzdem ist es sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Ich meine, was ich toll finde, das ist das, was Frank wahrscheinlich auch genießt, ist die Tatsache, dass man in so einer Tauschbörse tatsächlich alle möglichen verrückten White Label oder Spezialaufnahmen von irgendwelchen DJ-Sets irgendwelcher Künstler in Paris aus dem Jahre 1994 zweite Jahreshälfte findet, wo dann das und das drauf ist, wo alle von Schwärmen, was man auf CD nie kriegen würde, weil es nie einer rausbringt. Das wird natürlich nie passieren bei Apple.
Ja, sowas kann wahrscheinlich kein kommerzielles Unternehmen bieten. Sowas bieten auch die Plattenläden. Sowas bietet auch Amazon nur eingeschränkt.
Hast du dir mal in Deutschland die anderen Angebote angeschaut? Also Popfiles und was gibt es noch? Hilft mir gerade jemand?
Popfile ist auch das Einzige, was mir gerade präsent ist.
Popfile.de Ja, ich hab da eben gesagt, ich weiß leider nicht mal, welcher Name das war. Es war dann irgendwie so, dass ich nicht mal Probe hören konnte. Das heißt, ich wusste nicht genau, für was ich mich da eigentlich interessiere. Und ja, erst zahlen und dann irgendwas kaufen, das ist mir doch ein wenig zu dumm. Ich möchte schon wissen, was ich kaufe.
Da hat es ja dran, dass du kein Windows benutzt, sondern Mac oder? Also war das so ein Systemproblem oder war das das Problem, dass sie es generell nicht anbieten, also zum Probehören?
Es ging generell nicht. Ich musste irgendwie zum Probehören, musste ich mich anmelden und irgendwas abonnieren. Und das wollte ich natürlich nicht. Das war glaube ich nicht Popfile.
Ich weiß auch gerade nicht, was da gab. Also es gab ja bei diesem Digital Download-Day und da wurden irgendwie so ein paar Sachen gehypt, aber mir fallen jetzt auch gerade wieder nicht ein, weil es war auch komplett unwichtig.
Ich hab's auch irgendwie im Kopf. Es war auch wieder so ein komischer Kunstname irgendwie.
Die Webseiten sind auch echt upturned da von denen.
Ich such mal gerade ein paar.
Und glaubst du denn wirklich, dass diese Online-Download-Geschichten eine wirkliche Zukunft haben? Also jetzt deine ganz persönliche Meinung? Also ich hab schon gemerkt, dass du recht überzeugt davon bist. Glaubst du so, wenn du jetzt mal an deine Freunde, Bekannten denkst, dass sie das nutzen werden?
Also die Leute würden das auf jeden Fall nutzen. Ich nehme nur an, dass es aufgrund der Musikindustrie in den einzelnen europäischen Ländern nicht funktionieren wird. Also ich denk von der Seite wird blockiert werden.
Gut, aber es wird ja bei uns schon auch gemacht. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass es das gar nicht gibt, sondern die Major-Labels bei uns, die Plattenfirmen, haben ja schon auch Angebote im Netz.
Ja, ob die sich da wirklich einig werden? Also es wäre sehr zu hoffen und ich denke von den Leuten wird es auf jeden Fall angenommen werden.
Und was meinst du mit einig werden?
Ich habe gehört, dass Universal in Europa selber einen Online-Versand aufziehen wollte. Das heißt bei solchen, wenn die schon sehr viel Geld investiert haben, selber was zum Download anzubieten, dann werden die nicht alle Planungen beiseite lassen und jemand anderen das Geschäft machen lassen. Dann natürlich solche Sachen wie die GEMA, die auch nicht einverstanden sein wird.
Also du siehst so einen Vorteil darin, dass du einen zentralen Ort hast im Prinzip, wo du die Musik von verschiedenen Platten-Labels kaufen kannst?
Es ist sehr bequem, wenn man tatsächlich einfach nur in irgendeinem Suchfeld einen Namen von einem Sänger eingibt und gezeigt bekommt, welche Platten tatsächlich zur Verfügung stehen und was man sich alles runterladen könnte. Das ist super bequem, klar. Wenn ich erst wissen muss, bei welchen verschiedenen Labels er schon gewesen ist, bevor ich weiß, wo ich suchen muss, ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht können wir das ja als Hausaufgabe an die Plattenfirmen geben.
Das packen wir mit auf die Liste, das ist auf jeden Fall super. Also Orientierung ist schon mal was.
Ja, ich hab natürlich gesucht und nicht das gefunden, was ich gesucht habe. Es gibt noch OD2 und E-Music und so, aber das sind alles amerikanische Dienste. Es gibt noch irgendwie so einen komischen...
OD2 sind aber glaube ich die technischen Abwickler, die zumindest dieses Download-Day-Geschichte gemacht haben. Leider benutzen sie kein Windows oder kein Internet Explorer.
Richtig, genau, da hatten wir schon verloren. Und wenn man überhaupt auf die Seite drauf gekommen ist, das war ja ohnehin schon eine Abenteuer. Antje, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ihr könnt auch anrufen oder 3177.110. Chaosradio-Thema heute Abend, Urheberrecht, auch in Sachen Musik und Musik-Downloaden. Wir wollten eigentlich einen Schritt weitergehen, weil wir schon zwei Stunden hinter uns haben in der Diskussion. Und ich gebe einfach mal rüber an Andi, der mir gerade so fest zuzwinkert, weil Andi da noch ein bisschen weitergehend formulieren wollte und wir ein bisschen theoretischer werden wollten jetzt die letzte Stunde.
Wollten wir das? Na gut. Also ich hatte neulich, wie gesagt, das fing nur mit dem Deutschen Kulturrat zu diskutieren mit einem Herrn, dessen Name ich leider gerade wieder vergessen habe. Und der hat sozusagen nochmal eine grundlegendere Forderung aufgestellt, die finde ich das Problem auch nochmal schön beleuchtet. Es ist ja so, dass bei Musik nur ein Eigentumsrecht im Sinne von ein Urheberrecht zugestanden wird, für 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Künstlers. Das heißt, dem seine Kinder, die können gerade nochmal von den Rechten leben, aber dann ist eben schuld. Und er sagt sich, warum ist das denn überhaupt so? Wenn wir uns ein Haus kaufen oder irgendwas, dann ist das ja auch uns. Und das heißt nochmal die Frage, ob das überhaupt alles so weitergeht. Weil wir haben ja hier doch einen Konflikt. Das eine sind sozusagen die technischen Realitäten des Internets, die diesen freien Austausch ermöglichen. Und das andere sind die Leute, die da Produkte sehen und die ja dann auch nicht davon reden, dass sich da jemand undizensiert etwas runterlädt, sondern die sagen, da ist Diebstahl, da wird gestohlen. Und also wenn man sich diese GVU anguckt, wie gesagt, das sind die Jungs, die fordern, dass jeder dritte Internetbenutzer doch mindestens mal ins Gefängnis müsste. Die wollen das halt auch durchziehen. Und die Frage, die ich nochmal hier in den Raum und auch an die Hörer stellen wollte, ist eigentlich, könntet ihr euch auch andere Methoden vorstellen, nach denen Künstler ihre Miete bezahlen könnten? Nehmen wir mal an, dass das Internet sich insofern durchsetzt, als dass es natürlich sowas wie diese Apple iTunes Geschichte geben wird. Das heißt, es wird die Möglichkeit geben, legal, das heißt, mit einem auch bezahlten Anteil an die Künstlermusik runter sich zu laden und zu kaufen, beziehungsweise es wird vielleicht auch Donationsysteme geben, das heißt, man darf das alles umsonst und frei verfügbar, aber Jungs, denkt auch mal an die Künstler und spendet auch mal was. Und trotzdem wird es die Möglichkeit geben, das werden sie ja nicht richtig verbieten können, oder verbieten werden sie schon können, aber technisch nicht unterbinden können, dass man eben Sachen kopiert. Das heißt, die Frage ist, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass das sozusagen so friedlich so weitergeht? Würdet ihr auch so freiwillig was zahlen? Nehmen wir mal an, technisch könntet ihr weiter kopieren, was ihr wollt, und die Suchmaschinen würden nicht nur funktionieren, sondern die Tauschbörsen auch, und die Qualität wäre besser. Würdet ihr auch freiwillig was zahlen, oder meint ihr, das taugt nicht hin? Und dann müsste man irgendwie für die Künstler vielleicht etwas anderes überlegen. So, dass man mal den Hut rumgeht, oder Konzerte, oder keine Ahnung, die Radiosender. Also die Labels reden ja auch davon, dass mittlerweile die meisten Platten oder viele Künstler machen das auch so. Die ziehen von Club zu Club und verkaufen einfach bei ihren Gigs. Also wenn die da irgendwie Musik machen oder so, dann verkaufen sie mehr Platten als normal an einem Laden. Das liegt auch daran, dass dieser Tons dieser Welt, oder die Media-Märkte, oder wie sie alle heißen, mittlerweile so eine Quote pro Quadratzentimeter ihres Ladens ausgesprochen haben, wieviel Return of Investor kommen muss. Und entsprechend die Top 100, die kriegt man da noch. Aber so abgefahrene Musik, die kriegste da auch gar nicht mehr.
Also ich hab ja auch einen Musikerkumpel, der sagt zum Beispiel, also ich kenne ja dessen Schicksal, er ist ein super Musiker, die Bands, für die der nur arbeitet als Bühnenmusiker, die müssten auf Tour gehen, weil die nur damit ihre Kohle verdienen. Alles andere ist für die irrelevant. Also die freuen sich, wenn sie dann ein paar T-Shirts verkaufen und die machen mit dem Konzert die Einnahmen. Die müssen touren, um die Kohle wieder reinzukriegen.
Die verkaufen auch oft mehr Platten, wie gesagt, an so einem Abend, wenn die dann T-Shirts und eben Platten verkaufen. Weil die Fans teilweise das Problem haben, dass die einfach in den normalen Plattenleben, gibt es ja so auch nicht mehr überall. Dann sind ja oftmals nur noch diese Elektronik-Media-Dings da Märkte und da kriegst du eben nicht alles. Und kannst es auch teilweise nicht mal bestellen.
Interessantes Modell war, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer mir das erzählt hatte, der Idee hatte einfach, vielleicht sollte die GEMA doch einfach so eine Tauschbörse aufmachen. Weil die haben ja auch das Problem, dass sie diese ganzen Pauschalabgaben aus den CD-Lehrmere, den Medien, also wenn ihr einen CD-Rolling kauft, dann wird ja da auch ein bestimmter Betrag in so einen großen Topf geschmissen von der GEMA und daraus werden dann auch wieder Künstler ausbezahlt nach einem Schlüssel. Dieser Schlüssel ist irgendwie noch schwer diskussionswürdig und da gehen auch irgendwie Klagen hin und her und das ist irgendwie alles eine ganz, ganz problematische Sache. Das denke ich führt aber irgendwie zu weit weg. Aber die Idee war einfach, dass die GEMA so eine Tauschbörse aufmacht, weil die wissen dann natürlich am besten, welche Titel irgendwie interessant sind. Und es könnte diesen Verteilschlüssel beeinflussen, wie denn dieses Geld aus den Lehrmedien-Abgaben und aus diesen Pauschalabgaben verteilt wird.
Oder sie könnten natürlich, wenn du dir so ein Ding downloads, dir sofort zwei Cent dafür abziehen, dass du das darunter lädst, das wäre natürlich auch schön. Einfach so ein Obolus.
Oder wenn es ein Agreement gäbe, der Tauschbörsen untereinander, dass sie im Prinzip so eine anonymisierten Liste der Top Ten downloads oder was auch immer downloads, an die Verwertungsgesellschaften geben.
Dann wär das im Grunde wie ein Radio zu verstehen, dass man nur selber bestimmen kann, so wie ein Internetradio. Ok, was denkt ihr über sowas? Also das sind alles Spinnereien über alternative Systeme, alternativ zu allen Ausprägungen und Zielblüten von Digital Rights Management. Würdet ihr zugunsten der Tatsache, dass ihr das einfach so kopieren und machen könnt, damit was ihr wollt auch sagen, ich gebe so einem Künstler auch was, wenn mir die Musik gefällt, spende ich dem sozusagen was. Also so hilfsbedürftiger Künstler, hier hast du ein Euro in dein Hütchen. Würdet ihr sowas machen? 0331 77 97 110 und ist das die Alternative? Erstmal ist der Martin am Telefon, hallo Martin. Guten Abend.
Das ist sehr witzig, weil ich hab das gerade als Diplom. Ja, ich mach irgendwie so Kommunikationsmanagement und das war jetzt auch nur so theoretisch, also nicht unbedingt praktisch, als ob das jetzt was wird, aber sozusagen eine Weiterführung dieser Copicels-Music-Kampagne. Und da gehts dann halt auch, also da hab ich ja auch ziemlich viele Daten drüber und sowas um was es geht, also warum die Leute jetzt gerade runterziehen, also die meisten ziehen's ja rum, weil es halt irgendwie 80% oder so, weil es halt irgendwie die Musik umsonst bekommen. Und da gibt's halt irgendwie ein Studium von der Gesellschaft für Konsumforschung, wenn ihr das kennt, diese Brenner-Studie. Die ist irgendwie jetzt vom Monat 15. April oder so ist rausgekommen, da wurden knapp 10.000 Leute gefragt und das scheint doch recht repräsentant zu sein. Und da geht's halt auch um dieses Kopieren hauptsächlich und viele Brennerei und dann halt auch die Fragerei oder die Frage, warum es jetzt sozusagen aus dem Internet runtergeladen wird. Und da ist es auch sehr interessant, wenn man überlegt, dass 80% die Sachen runterladen, weil sie es umsonst bekommen können, oder andersrum wieder auch an den Leuten 70% das auch runterladen, weil sie halt ihre eigenen Sampler zusammenstellen wollen, merkt man auch, dass das ein ganz schöner Unterschied ist. Also gibt es zwar die Leute, denen es ziemlich egal ist, dass es umsonst ist, dass sie den Künstlern damit den weiteren Weg verbauen oder den Newcomern oder sowas, und es gibt auch die Leute, die aufgrund des Angebots wirklich nur da zurückgreifen, ihre Sachen illegal runterzuziehen. Weil wenn sie eine Maxi kaufen wollen, die 4 Euro kostet, weil sie nur ein Lied haben wollen und nicht 5 Versionen, ziehen sie sich lieber nur ein Lied runter.
Gäbs da auch irgendwelche Fragen dazu, ob die Leute dann auch wieder mehr Musik gekauft haben, also CDs gekauft haben daraufhin?
Ja, genau, da gibt es ja auch die Leute, die mehr Musik deswegen kaufen oder weniger. Es gibt auf jeden Fall einige, ich muss jetzt noch mal kurz runter nachschauen, aber es gibt auch einige, die auf jeden Fall mehr Musik kaufen, deswegen auch, aber es sind viel mehr Prozent, die weniger Musik deswegen kaufen. Also es ist nicht diese Plus Minus Null von wegen tauschen, macht den Künstler berühmt und ich möchte jemanden, meinem Kumpel oder so was, die Musik näherbringen, sondern es wird schon mehr gezogen und mehr geklaut als vorher.
Sag mal, die GFK, wer ist denn das eigentlich? Oder wo kriegen die ihre Aufträge für diese Studien her?
Das ist diese Gesellschaft für Konsumforschung. Der Auftrag ist schon von der Phono-Gesellschaft, von der ESB. Das ist schon klar, Forschung ist immer nur so weit raus, wovon der Auftraggeber ist, und dank Forschung kann man fälschen. Aber ich denke mal, so wie sie rüberkommt, ist sie schon sehr repräsentant.
Glaube ich ja nicht. Ich glaube ja eher, dass die Studie genau die Fragen gestellt hat, die die gerne hören wollten.
Du meinst sie Antworten gegeben hat, die sie hören wollten?
Nee, sondern die Fragen. Natürlich letztendlich die Antworten. Aber was ich damit sagen will, ist, je nachdem wie man Leute fragt, antworten sie ja auch.
Sind die Fragen, also die Fragebögen oder so was, sind die offen?
Ich hab die leider nicht vor mir. Ich hab ja nicht die komplette Studie oder so.
Hey, ihr seid ja wieder richtig wach, Jungs.
Aber wie hältst du denn das selbst? Wärst du denn bereit, wenn ich kurz darauf zurückkomme, sag eigentlich unsere Frage, auch freiwillig, nehmen wir mal an, das würde jetzt umsonst alles in anständiger Qualität verfügbar sein, was es ja teilweise auch ist, wirst du bereit, da auch freiwillig ein paar Euro einfach dem Künstler zuzuwerfen, wenn das technisch einfach ginge?
Freiwillig? Also meinst du das noch nicht mal nach dem Motto, ich ziehe mir seine Songs runter und zahle jetzt direkt für den Song?
Nö, sondern dass der Künstler sozusagen, du hast dir das MP3 runtergeladen und jetzt gibt es da so ein Logo, ey Alter, schön, dass du meine Musik geil findest, aber meine Miete muss ich auch noch bezahlen, was hältst du davon, wenn du hier mal auf diesen Knopf drückst und mir ein Euro rüberwirfst?
Ja, finde ich ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine richtige Sache. Also man sollte auf jeden Fall die Künstler, die Künstler, die man mag, auch unterstützen, aber ich weiß nicht, also die kennt das ja auch, die Plattenindustrie, die ist halt so dieses Ding, das sind auch, man braucht halt so eine normale Plattenindustrie.
Ja, die sind mit ihren Geschäftsfotos so ein bisschen unflexibel.
Na, das Problem ist einfach, dass die ja dann nichts davon haben, wenn du direkt an den Musiker bezahlst, dann hat er die Plattenfirma nichts davon.
Ja, die hat dann nicht wirklich was davon, aber der Musiker braucht ja auch jemanden, der ihn eigentlich, weil er ist ja Künstler, und er will ja eigentlich nicht seine Zeit damit vergeuden, zu überlegen, wer ihn jetzt hören möchte. Also dafür hat er eigentlich nicht die Zeit, also möchte er sich darauf konzentrieren, seine Musik zu machen. Denn es ist ja egal, wo jetzt so eine Plattenfirma ist, oder jemanden, der denen jetzt irgendein Internetportal, wo es dann halt gesagt wird, hier ist die neue Rockmusik, weil, wie ihr wisst, es gibt tausende von Bands und es gibt tausende von Internetseiten, aber ich möchte ja auch irgendwie, ich brauch ja Empfehlung. Ich muss ja irgendwo reinhören. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die sehr informieren oder sowas, aber manche Leute kriegen das halt wirklich nur über Fritz mit oder weiß nicht selbst, über Energy oder sowas. Man muss ja gewisse Empfehlungen haben, oder man muss ja ungefähr wissen, wo man hin will. Das heißt, da gibt es dann auch Vermittler oder sowas, und die möchten ja dann auch was verdienen. Da ist das nun ein Internetportal. Okay, ihr seid gut, und ich sag jetzt hier, hört mal die Musikrichtung an, Richtung Dance oder so, die sind sehr gut.
Und die Musik muss ja auch erstmal aufgenommen werden, professionell.
Ja, all diese Sachen, da sind ja so viele Leute dran, die das irgendwie...
Also zum Beispiel, das Ding ist, es gibt natürlich, muss ich jetzt mal so einspringen, sowas wie MP3Com, ich glaube, meines Wissens funktionieren die so, dass da bestimmte Foren angehängt sind, und da darf jeder seine Musik einfach reinstellen. Im Grunde ist das so das demokratische Prinzip. Da hast du viel, viel Dreck und bestimmt auch den guten, den einen oder anderen guten Track. Und das Ganze funktioniert so Community-mäßig nach dem Motto, Hotfile, das und das wurde so und so oft runtergeladen, oder das und das kann ich euch empfehlen. Trotzdem ist MP3Com nicht das, wo die Masse brummt momentan. Also die Frage ist natürlich auch, ob das unabhängig von allen möglichen Rechten, die da immer angewandt werden, einfach so ein Gewöhnungsfaktor ist, dass die Leute sich dran gewöhnt haben, hey, ich hab hier den super produzierten amerikanischen Song, der hört sich so und so an, und da kommt der Normalbürger einfach nicht ran an die fetten Beats von Doktor So und So, weißt du?
Ja, aber die Sachen, es werden ja hauptsächlich auch nur die Charts kopiert und gebrannt. Das wird ja nicht jetzt irgendwie der Doktor So und So, also wenn jetzt nicht Doktor Drehmeins oder so, aber es wird jetzt nicht irgendein unbekannter Künstler großartig gebrannt und deswegen gehypt, sondern es werden wirklich, weißte nicht, die Media-Control-Charts oder die Charts, die gekauft werden, lassen sich eigentlich hier in Deutschland parallel mit dem, was runtergezogen wird. Da leiden ja auch diese Compilations hauptsächlich darunter und gesingelt.
Das Problem ist doch aber auch, dass wenn jetzt gerade unbekanntere Künstler, die eh schon wenig Platten verkaufen und wenn davon auch dann noch welche runtergeladen werden, dann kriegen die ja noch weniger.
Genau und einerseits, also diese, weißte nicht, so, diese Superstars, wie Scheiße sie auch sein mögen oder so was, oder Geschmack, ja wie gesagt. Aber die Leute, die füttern halt noch neun bis zehn Künstler durch. Also in der Industrie oder so was, nur zehn Prozent schaffen es wirklich, dass sie bekannt werden. Und den Rest sind die Kohle, die da reingesteckt wurde, weil halt irgendein Armeher dachte, okay, die bringen es. Aber es hat halt irgendwie, was zu gründen ist, hat halt nicht geklappt, weil es so viele sind oder weil er nicht Dolle ist. Und das heißt, 90 Prozent schreiben halt rote Zahlen. Und deswegen ist die Sache, also von wegen auch, okay, wenn ich mir sage, Eminem oder auch sonst wer verdient genug, die kann ich mir auch unterziehen. Okay, aber er füttert halt auch noch neuen Künstler weiter.
Wobei das auch die Standardargumentation der Plattenfirmen ist, das muss man also auch dazu sagen. Und die Leute, die jetzt gerade diese MP3- und Downloadgeschichten verfechten, das sind eben, die sagen halt, naja, wir wollen hier mal Zahlen sehen. Also weil so ist es nicht, weil als kleine Band hast du einfach erst mal die Arschkarte gezogen. Da kriegst du nämlich nichts davon, sondern musst halt auch erstmal irgendwie in Vorleistung gehen. Und im Prinzip scheint also dieses große Geld, was die Superstars da noch einfahren, möglicherweise da einfach zu versegern, zu verdampfen in der Plattenfirma. Also das ist zwar halt dieser Ansatz, den die Plattenfirmen vertreten, ist in der Realität, würde ich mal sagen, irgendwie sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Ja, okay, dann bin ich es wahrscheinlich auch, weil ich jetzt sehr viel von denen gelesen habe, ein bisschen auch zu sehr auf die eingestimmt. Aber ich sehe es auch selber als Musikliebhaber, dass sie natürlich auch sehr Bronches, die natürlich auch sehr gerne heult und auch gerne, wie gesagt, die P2P und sowas schreit, ohne wirklich zu überlegen.
Das ist halt der Gewöhnungseffekt. Wer noch viel Kohle verdient hat, möchte, dass es auch gerne so bleibt. Also dann irgendwie so in den klassischen Lumpenstatus zurückzufallen und wieder Student zu leben, das wollen die nicht gerne. Das ist aber auch zu verstehen bei so einem riesen Apparat. Aber vielleicht müssen wir es einfach nur mal wieder lernen. Vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend. Dir auch. Das Chaosradio heute Abend, wir haben noch eine knappe Stunde, ist gelogen. Wir haben noch ungefähr 45 Minuten Zeit uns mit euch zu unterhalten. Ihr euch mit uns und ihr könnt reden unter 0373 77 91 10 im Studio Frank-Rosengard, Andy Müller, Magun und Max von Malodki. Und ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich noch eine Seite gefunden, auf der diese ganzen Download-Dienste nochmal drauf waren. Irgendeiner von denen wird es wahrscheinlich gewesen sein. Wer hat nämlich vorhin darüber gesprochen? Rhapsody gab es da, Pressplay, wahrscheinlich war es Pressplay, ne? Ach so, okay und Liquid Audio hatten wir noch und dann hat mich gerade ein Hörer angerufen und meinte puretunes.com und da hab ich mal geguckt, das ist ein All-You-Can-Eat-Prinzip. Da steht so, was stand da?
Das war kein deutscher Anbieter, glaube ich.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. All-You-Can-Download, 3, 50 Euro für 8 Stunden.
Das war gerade auf Heise, glaube ich.
Ach so, okay, was ganz Neues, ja.
Dann gibt es irgendwie noch was in Spanien. Da sind die auch gerade aber fürchterlich am Rotieren. Da geht es gerade wieder diese Verwertungsgesellschaften und die Plattenfirmen hier sagen, ey, das könnt ihr doch nicht machen. Also das ist halt gerade das Internet dadurch, dass es eben nicht an Ländergrenzen und an diese bisherigen Vermarktungswege gebunden ist, ist da ein richtiges Problem für die Plattenfirmen in dem Fall.
Was denkt ihr, sollte das Ganze in eine andere Richtung gehen, sollten Sachen jetzt auf einmal, also vielleicht eben auch downloadbar und bezahlt werden? Also wenn sie downloadbar sind, was würdet ihr dafür bezahlen? Würdet ihr das haben wollen und in welche Richtung sollte das eurer Meinung nach gehen werden? Gerade eben von Andi den Vorschlag, dass das auch mit Donation, also wie Donationware funktioniert, das gibt es von der Software aus gesehen. Das heißt, irgend einer stellt sein Programm zum Download. Das ist ohne Einschränkungen downloadbar. Ihr könnt machen damit, was ihr möchtet und wenn ihr denkt, hey, das Programm bringt mir was, dann könnt ihr diesem Programmierer oder in dem Fall dem Künstler, der die Musik gemacht hat, was spenden, wenn ihr möchtet. Glaubt ihr, das wäre ein cooles Prinzip? Ja oder nein? 031 77 97 110. Die Nummer und am Telefon ist der Rainer. Hallo Rainer. Rainer, bist du noch da? Ne, ja sorry, wenn ihr lange warten müsst, wir sind teilweise von Argumentationsketten heute Abend sehr lang im Chaosradio. Aber vielleicht ist der Frank noch da. Hallo Frank.
Tagchen. Meine Frage rüstet ein bisschen vom Thema ab. Und zwar, ihr hattet ja auch vorhin vom Kopierprogramm gesprochen. Und da habe ich, also ich bin jemand, der DVDs rippt. Auf CDs. Und da gibt es ja von SAD so ein Movie-Jack-Programm. Und die machen ja jetzt auch eine Verfassungsflage. Und da wollte ich nur mal eure Meinung zu hören, ob ihr da meint, die haben auch eine Chance mit der Klage durchzukommen.
Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz sagen weswegen genau die klagen? Ich kenne den Fall nicht.
Also die sammeln auch im Internet wohl so Unterschriften. Es geht wohl darum, dass die Leute ja eine rechtstoffene Kopie haben, aber dass die Programme ja wohl für die Erstellung der Kopien verboten werden sollen.
Sozusagen, bzw. die Umgehung von technischen Schutzmechanismen, wenn so sie denn vorhanden sind, wird verboten.
Ja und da ist halt die Firma SAD auf dem Standpunkt, dass dadurch ihre Programme, dass sie die der Kommunismus sozusagen in eine Tonne schmeißen können.
Ich glaube, die brauchen ein bisschen PR im Moment. Also meine persönliche Meinung.
Was ich aktuell gelesen habe war, dass die alle sehr unsicher sind angesichts dieser Urheberrechtsnovelle in Deutschland, weil die eben halt nicht wissen, ob möglicherweise in Kürze irgendwann diese Programme verboten werden. Weil momentan kann man noch alles damit machen, aber wird es dem User überlassen bleiben, sozusagen die Rechte einhalten zu müssen und es gibt die Programme noch, oder wird man bei den Programmen ansetzen? Das ist noch nicht klar.
Ja klar, das Problem ist, dass insbesondere die gewerbliche Herstellung, Verbreitung, Verkauf, Bewerbung, blablabla, von so Programmen, die eben technische Schutzmechanismen geneigt sind zu umgehen, dann tatsächlich eine Straftat ist. Da haben die natürlich keinen Bock drauf in die Kategorie.
Ja, bloß eine Frage ist die. Sofern nutzt mir das, wenn ich als Privatperson recht scharfe eine Kopie herzustellen und aber überhaupt kein Programm dafür auf dem Markt ist, um die Kopie herzustellen.
Ja, das ist im Grunde genommen ja auch unser grundlegender Vorwurf so ein bisschen an die Politik gewesen, als wir gesagt haben, also in dem Moment, wo man der Industrie einen Plankoscheck ausstellt, nämlich, dass sie Schutzmechanismen welcher technischen Art auch immer entwickeln können und diese Schutzmechanismen juristischen Schutz genießen. In dem Moment ist ja total alles andere, was da im Gesetz steht, sozusagen wurscht, weil die Industrie dann ja definieren kann über ihre technischen Schutzmechanismen, was sozusagen juristisch zulässig ist und was nicht. Die haben das zumindest für den Bereich, wo also diese Schranken, der Begriff meint, also sowas wie Bibliotheken, also Ausnahmen vom Verbot, das nennen die eine Schranke, das ist ja auch irgendwie ein merkwürdiger Begriff, aber egal. Und also bei Bibliotheken und ähnliches, da haben sie explizit gesagt, da müssen sozusagen die rechte Inhaber dann technische Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung stellen, dass eben die Bibliotheken und andere eben diese Ausnahmeregelung tatsächlich auch wahrnehmen können und dass sie eben nicht da einzementiert werden. Aber für den privaten Anwender ist das noch so ein bisschen unklar und im Moment liegt das Ding ja beim Vermittlungsausschuss zwischen Bundestag und Bundesrat. Also die schlussendliche Definition kann ich dir jetzt auch noch nicht sagen, wo es bei hinauslaufen wird, aber zumindest ist das Problem mit in der Debatte bereits mehrfach und laut genannt worden.
Zwei Sachen, also zum einen denke ich, dass genau dieser Paragraph, was Jojo Sven auch schon angesprochen hat im Interview, die Sache mit dieser Wirksamkeit der technischen Maßnahmen, das muss natürlich dann im Einzelfall jeweils vom Gericht geprüft werden müssen. Also ob jetzt zum Beispiel ein komplexes DRM-System, wo Verschlüsselungsgeschichten eingebaut sind, Wasserzeichen und sowas, das wird mit Sicherheit anders bewertet werden als jetzt irgendwie so ein paar beabsichtigte Knackser auf der CD oder eine manipulierte Table of Content von so einer CD, ob das jetzt als Kopierschutz durchgeht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist dir seit den 80er Jahren irgendein Kopierschutz bekannt, der wirksam war?
Also da ist wahrscheinlich die Frage, kann ich nur spekulieren, wie hoch der Aufwand getrieben werden muss oder wie komplex es ist.
Ja gut, da bin ich das Beispiel, aber das Problem an dem die da arbeiten, ist doch Datenverarbeitungsmaschinen daran zu verhindern, Daten zu verarbeiten. Und ich hab da meine Zweifel, ob das funktionieren wird, komm mal jemals.
Meinst du, ob es technisch verhindert wird oder juristisch verhindert wird?
Nein, nein, technisch. Es geht ja hier um die Wirksam, ist ja wohl ein Begriff, der irgendwie bedeutet, dass da nicht nur Kopierschutzmechanismus draufsteht, sondern dass das eben auch tatsächlich auch einer ist und nicht nur eine beabsichtigte Bitschubserei sozusagen.
Richtig, genau. Und da haben wir ja das Problem, dass es nämlich im Gesetzentwurf soweit offen gelassen ist, dass hinterher auf jeden Fall ein Richter entscheiden muss im Einzelfall, ob das irgendwie eine wirksame Sache ist oder nicht.
Ich guck nochmal, da gibt es bestimmt eine lustige Definition.
Das kann passieren auf jeden Fall. Wobei ich immer noch denke, dass auch ein bisschen der Markt die Sache regeln wird. Also das heißt, wenn die CDs bis zum Geld nur kopiergeschützt sind oder irgendwelche Sachen drin sind und die Leute das Scheiße finden, dann kaufen sie die CDs nicht mehr. Also ich würde jedenfalls keine CD mehr kaufen, die kopiergeschützt ist. Allein deswegen, weil sie kopiergeschützt ist. Und vielleicht checken es die Leute irgendwann mal. Und dann reguliert sich das über den Markt. Weil in Amerika zum Beispiel habe ich gelesen, dass es da gar nicht so weit ist mit dem Kopierschutz.
Ja, da muss ich sagen, da fällt mir jetzt diese Musik-CD als Beispiel ein. Also die Hersteller haben ja diese Normen total verbogen. Also da gibt es ja diese CD-Normen praktisch von der Musik-CD. Die erfüllt ja gar nicht mehr die Normen, die es eigentlich sein soll. Und die scheren sich auch direkt rum. Und trotzdem werden Musik-CDs nach wie vor in Deutschland verkauft, obwohl sie kopiergeschützt sind.
Ja, weil die Leute ihre Verbraucherrechte nicht wahrnehmen.
Ja, leider. Da hat es zum Beispiel auch so ein Programm wie Tlone-CD ein. Die reparieren ja in dem Sinne nur die, oder nehmen den Kopierschutz raus und machen da die CD so, dass sie auch in meinen Computerlauf fähig ist.
Das ist die Frage, welchen Anspruch die Gesellschaft da an sich haben will. Ob sie jetzt sagen, solange es halt noch die Programme gibt, die das halt alles irgendwie rausmachen, ist ja kein Problem, ich kauf die CD trotzdem. Oder ob die Leute jetzt sagen wirklich so, ich bringe die CD jetzt im Laden zurück, ich will jetzt die Plattenfirma ankacken, ich geh dann notfalls vor Gericht mit. Und um diese Sachen auch durchzusetzen, diese Rechte, das ist halt eine Frage, in welcher Gesellschaft wir leben. Ob die Leute so sagen, geht ja noch irgendwie. Oder ob sie da auch gegen aufstehen.
Also ich denke mal, die werden wahrscheinlich eher nicht gegen aufstehen. Wenn man sich das so mal so mal anklickt, was in Deutschland so ist, da steht ja niemand für irgendwas auf.
Außer für billiges Benzin, Hunde und...
Mickey-Maus-Telefone, verchromte Acrylglasklos. Nichts vergessen.
Aber ihr seid wie... Diese Info, die war auch vor kurzem jetzt in seiner Computerzeitung, ab dem 1. Juni praktisch, sämtliche Kopierprogramme verboten sind, das ist dann erstmal richtig.
Naja, solange das Gesetz nicht verabschiedet ist, weil im Alten steht es ja so nicht drin.
Ja, Moment. Naja, das ist das eine, aber das andere ist, dass man unterscheiden muss zwischen gewerblichen Aktivitäten in dem Kontext und nicht gewerblichen Aktivitäten. Da macht der Gesetzgeber also wirklich einen Unterschied. Das betrifft halt auch die private Gruppie. Die gilt selbstverständlich nicht. Also privat meint eben auch nicht gewerblich und so weiter und so fort. Also da kann man ja auch ein bisschen Verständnis für haben, weil wenn man jetzt sagt, man hat keine Kohle und deswegen kopiert man sich die Musik nun mal so, das ist eine Sache. Aber wenn man sozusagen dafür Geld nimmt und dieses Geld dann nicht mehr der Künstler bekommt, das ist ja dann doch irgendwie, da könnte man dann sagen, also das ist irgendwie moralisch auch so ein bisschen fragwürdig. Im Bezug auf den sozusagen das mit der Wirksamkeit, ich google hier gerade ein bisschen rum, aber ich befürchte, ich habe das noch nicht gefunden. Vielleicht hat irgend ein Hörer diese Definition. Also ich weiß nämlich, dass der Bundestag hat sich daran versucht, das zu definieren, was Wirksamkeit eines Kopierschutzes ist. Das war ein ziemlich lustiger Satz, aber ich finde ihn gerade nicht. Ich brauche noch ein paar Minuten.
Dann ein kleines Intermezzo.
Die einen sagen Disco-Roller. Die anderen sagen Rollerskates. Wir sagen Rollschuhe sind schwer im Kommen.
Und was kommt, kommt bei uns und im Radio.
Ich bin noch dabei, aber vielleicht hat er einen Hörer.
Vielleicht hört ja ein Verfassungsrichter dazu.
Hallo, ich habe da also noch mal einen Link, um diese Initiative der Firma hier geht. Und zwar www.copyswide.de Auch nicht schädlich.
Ansonsten hätte ich noch www.privatcopy.net anzubieten. Das ist eine Initiative, an der wir auch teilgenommen haben, die sich eben insbesondere für diesen Aspekt der Privat kopieren. Wir haben da eine ziemlich umfangreiche Linksammlung, die ist leider so umfangreich, dass ich gerade diese Definition im Gesetzestext nicht finde.
Aber... Frank, vielen Dank erst mal. Macht es gut, schafft es schön. Und ihr könnt natürlich mitdiskutieren. Und wenn ihr diesen Link kennt, oder wenn ihr diese Ausschnitte kennt, wo es um die Diskussion der Tatsache geht, was ein wirksamer Kopierschutz ist, könnt ihr auch teilnehmen. Oder 377 97 110. Oder natürlich, wenn ihr grundsätzlich eure Meinung zu dem Thema im Chaos Radio loswerden möchtet. Andi Müller-Magun, Frank Rosengart und Max von Malottke im Studio. Und am Telefon der Manfred. Hallo, Manfred.
Ja, den Link hab ich leider nicht. Aber ich wollte was noch zu Vermarktung von den CDs noch mal sagen. Es wurde jetzt noch nicht so eindeutig gesagt, dass die Künstler von jeder verkauften CD nur 75 Cent ungefähr bekommen. Das ist ja auch ziemlich skandalös, finde ich jedenfalls.
Du meinst, der Anteil der sozusagen für Marketing, Rechtsabteilung, Anti-Kopierschutz-Kampagnen und ähnlichen Blödsinn drauf geht.
Ja, die ganze Musikindustrie, die verdient am meisten von einer verkauften CD. Die handeln nur so 1, 50 Euro und die Herstellung 1 Euro. Der Rest geht in die Musikindustrie, in die Vermarktung und Werbung. Das unterstütze ich auch nicht gern. Das wollte ich noch mal sagen. Wenn ich jetzt einen Titel kaufen würde für 99 Cent, zum Beispiel im Internet, dann ist es im Endeffekt dann auch nichts anderes, wenn das die Musikindustrie macht. Dann gehen von den 99 Cent auch vielleicht nur 5 Cent an den Künstler. Und das andere funktioniert genauso mit den Anteilen. Bis auf den Handel vielleicht dann. Aber das müsste dann schon anders laufen. Ich würde schon Geld bezahlen für einen Musiktitel. Aber dann müsste auch an den Künstler der größte Teil geben, finde ich jedenfalls. Und nicht an die Industrie und die Vermarktung und den ganzen Mittelpunkt.
Aber da ist ja genau wieder dieses Problem. Diese Vermarktung muss ja auch irgendwo sein. Irgendwie muss das ja alles aufgebaut werden, auch zum Künstler.
Ja gut, aber das muss im Verhältnis stehen. Das muss angemessen sein, finde ich jedenfalls. Das ist für mich so nicht angemessen. Also ich würde schon Geld bezahlen für Musik. Ich bin noch nichts runtergeladen. Ich habe auch kein DSL. Aber ich habe mir runterladen lassen von Freunden, also Musik. Aber da haben natürlich die Künstler gar nichts von, wenn man das so über diese Tauschblasen macht. Das finde ich nicht gut.
Das hatten sie natürlich früher beim Kopieren auch nicht. Wenn mein Kumpel mir eine Kassette gezogen hat, das klassische, wir fahren damit zum Kinotape, halbe Stunde die eine Seite. Dann war das natürlich auch was, wovon die Musikindustrie nichts hatte im Endeffekt. Das Problem ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Sache ist, wo so zwei Systeme aufeinander geklatscht sind, die miteinander nichts anfangen konnten. Weil das Ding ist, die Musikindustrie hat darauf aufgebaut, dass sie einen tierischen Werbeaufwand betreibt, um ihre Produkte, die sie in ihrem Netzwerk im Grunde anbietet, bekannt zu machen, damit die Leute innerhalb dieses Netzwerkes kaufen. Jetzt ist es so, dass sich da neben Netzwerk gebildet hat, dass die Sachen viel, viel besser an den Mann bringt und die Werbung im Grunde genauso greift. Die Werbung, die die für ihren Netzwerk machen, gilt auch für das andere Netzwerk. Du hast jetzt sowas wie Amazon, zum Beispiel, das gab es früher nicht. Das ist im Grunde wie dein eigener Verkäufer, den du immer dabei hast. Bei Amazon, wenn ich was kaufe, schreibe dir unten drunter, Kunden, die das gekauft haben, denen gefällt das auch. Das ist das cleverste überhaupt. Das ist sowas wie absolut gezielte Werbung auf den Punkt zu bringen, für das gleiche Produkt und dann im Grunde was anderes mit zu verkaufen. Solche Mechanismen gab es früher ja nicht. Und die Frage ist, ist die Musikindustrie im Grunde nicht nur altmodisch geworden, weil sie die Netzwerke nicht benutzt, sondern weil sie ihre Werbung einfach falsch einstellt auf was ganz anderes?
Ja, die Werbung, die ist zum Teil gar nicht mehr notwendig. Und die Ausgaben dafür bräuchten dann auch gar nicht mehr sein. Teilweise für die Vermarktung. Weil auf Wege des Internets wird es ja dann viel besser oder auch zum großen Teil vermarktet oder Werbung gemacht.
Also ich befürchte, dass da vielleicht so ein bisschen die Spitzen dann abweichen. Wie soll ich sagen, dass dann diese Möglichkeit nicht mehr da ist, dass auch bestimmte Sachen, bestimmte wirklich auch gute Bands auch irgendwie gut zur Spitze an den Erfolg gebracht werden.
Hä, warum? Ich meine, gute Sachen setzen sich doch durch. Also ich meine, es gibt natürlich marketingbezogene Musik, die irgendwie durch Marketing groß wird. Die wird dann einfach überall gedudelt und dann ist die eben groß. Und ich meine, man nebenbei bemerkt, die Musikindustrie arbeitet ja seit Jahrzehnten. Das wissen alle Künstler. Auch mit diesen Standard-Tricks, dass wenn man eine Band hypen will, dann kauft man eben auch in den Läden, deren Platten, um die Verkaufsquoten zu erhöhen, um in die Charts zu kommen, damit das dann umsonst gespielt wird, weil Musiksender nur da spielen, was in den Charts ist, blabla. Also diese ganzen Mauscheleien und Tricks und so, das ist ja alles ohnehin sind das quasi Gesetzmäßigkeiten innerhalb der Musikindustrie. Und insofern ist also das Argument dazu zu zahlen, dass dann coole Musiker nicht mehr an die Spitze kommen, das glaube ich nicht. Sondern also gute Musik setzt sich auch so durch.
Aber natürlich nicht in dem Maße, ne? Also ich meine, du wirst nie so viel Geld damit machen können, wie die jetzt damit machen. Darum geht's ihnen ja.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, das kommt drauf an. Ich meine mal im Ernst, Musiker verdienen ja teilweise auch schon ihre Kohle mit ganz absurden Sachen. Irgendwie, dass eben Jeanswerbung damit gespielt wird oder was auch immer. Also da gibt's ja...
Ja, aber willst du das als Maßstand nehmen, irgendwie?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein, wie gesagt, ich will jetzt aber auch nicht anfangen mit Sozialismus oder Barbarei. Aber die Kernfrage ist doch, ich meine, wenn es nun mal so ist, dass Musik frei verfügbar ist und die Künstler leben müssen, dann sind ja letztendlich wir, also diejenigen, die die Musik dann hören, sind diejenigen, die darum entscheiden, wollen wir, dass der Mann Millionär wird und sich 18 Villen kaufen kann und einen privaten Jet und noch 17 Frauen heiraten kann und so weiter und so fort. Oder wollen wir sagen, okay, der hat seine Miete gezahlt, der macht den Eindruck, er lebt da ganz gut. Vielleicht, ach, weißt du, ob ich jetzt noch da die neue Platte mir gleich kaufen muss, ich höre sie mir erst mal an und dann entscheide ich mal, ob ich der Meinung bin, okay, der muss sich jetzt dann doch noch den Leerjet 2 kaufen.
Aber das Problem ist, wenn es irgendwie zu viele Leute machen, denkst du, ach, naja, der hat ja vielleicht schon genug gehäht und so, dann hat er halt irgendwie da nichts mehr, dann kommt bei den Künstlern nix mehr an.
Ja, dann kann die Kohle woanders hin, das ist doch super. Dann kann der nächste Künstler kommen und kann sich auch endlich mal die Miete dadurch finanzieren. Nennt man Umverteilung, oder?
Ich dachte, du wolltest mit Sozialismus und Barbarie gar nicht anfangen.
Ich kann aber noch mal ablenken, ich habe jetzt auch die Definition von Wirksamkeit im Gesetzessext gefunden, und zwar wirksam ist also ein Schutzmechanismus, durch eine Zugangskontrolle, ein Schutzmechanismus, wie Verschlüsselung, Verzerrung oder sonstige Umwandlung oder ein Mechanismus zur Kontrolle der Vervielfältigung unter digitale Blompen gesteckt würden. Also, auf gut Deutsch, wirksam ist nicht die Definition, dass das funktioniert, sondern dass bestimmte Sachen gemacht werden, zum Beispiel eben eine Verschlüsselung, eine Verzerrung, eine Umwandlung oder ein Mechanismus zur Kontrolle der Vervielfältigung.
Ist doch lächerlich, nur dass es da ist, ist doch nicht wir-
Ja, ne, ne, die Juristen sagen auch, dass diese Definition völlig gaga ist.
Weil du musst jetzt aber auch sagen, woher kommt der Kommentar, ne? Das ist also, das ist ja kein...
Nein, das ist jetzt, nein, das ist jetzt tatsächlich hier direkt, so steht es im Gesetzestext.
Nee, so steht es nicht im Gesetzestext.
Also ihr zwei kebbelt euch und entscheidet das, wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten. Manfred, dank dir für den Anruf.
Ich wollte mal ganz kurz sagen, also, das neue Dienstag aus Spanien, wo man downloaden kann, das ist dieser Pure Tones. Pure Tunes oder Pure Tune.
Pure Tunes, genau, Entschuldigung, genau.
Das ist dieser neue Dienst aus Spanien, wo man für 4 Euro 8 Stunden lang runterladen kann oder ein Wochenende lang für 10 Euro oder 10 Dollar.
Kann man das auch hier nach Deutschland, also kann man das in Deutschland auch machen, von hier aus? Ach so, kann man auch, ja?
Ja, hab ich jetzt gelesen.
Ist natürlich spannend, was da so dahinter steckt.
10 Dollar am Wochenende und 4 Dollar 8 Stunden. Das ist wohl recht neu, ja. Die haben sich die Lizenzen von diesen Verwertungsgesellschaften eingekauft. Oder von diesen bestimmten. Und damit meinen sie sind auf der sicheren Seite. Aber trotzdem werden sie dann wahrscheinlich mit Klagen, wird ihnen gedroht werden, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, Spaß in Spanien. Okay, dank dir Manfred, mach's gut, tschüss. Wenn Fritz rundum bellt sich, dann 91, 9, 0 Uhr 34, mit dem Wetter in der Nacht wird es ein bisschen kühler, bei klarem Himmel 11 bis 7 Grad, morgen gibt es wieder viel Sonne, die Temperaturen steigen feiertagsgerecht auf maximal 27 Grad und jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heirich.
Der AC Mailand ist Europas neuer Fußball-Champion im italienischen Champions League-Finale gegen Juventus Turin gewonnen, die Mailander mit 3 zu 2 im Elfmeterschießen. Im Old Trafford-Stadion von Manchester war das Endspiel bis nach der Verlängerung torlos geblieben. Der erste ökumenische Kirchentag hat am Abend in Berlin begonnen. Zum Gottesdienst vor dem Brandenburger Tor kamen 140.000 Menschen. Zu den Teilnehmern sprachen auch Bundespräsident Rao und Bundeskanzler Schröder. Papst Johannes Paul II hatte sich mit einer Grußbotschaft an die katholischen und evangelischen Christen gewandt. Als Konsequenzen aus den jüngsten schweren Busumfällen will die Bundesregierung die Sicherheitsbestimmungen deutlich verschärfen. Verkehrsminister Stolpe kündigt in Berlin an, Manipulationen an Fahrtenschreibern und Tempo-Begrenzern künftig strafrechtlich zu verfolgen. Verstöße gegen vorgeschriebene Ruhezeiten und Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen sollen mit erhöhten Bußgeldern geahndet werden. Die Vereinten Nationen wollen 1000 Soldaten nach Kongo schicken. Die Eingreiftruppe unter französischem Kommando soll das Blutvergießen im Nordosten des zentralafrikanischen Landes unterbinden. Die Stationierung der multinationalen Truppe soll bereits am kommenden Sonntag beginnen.
Alle seine Konzerte sind total ausverkauft. Aber jetzt präsentiert Fritz... Herbert Grünemeier das Zusatzkonzert. Am 4. Juli live in der Wohlheide Berlin.
Die letzten Klänge vom Chaosradio, wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit. Großer Talk heute auf Fritz, am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wie immer im Zeichen digitaler Lebensaspekte. Und zwar in diesem Fall der Frage, die wir schon seit zweieinhalb Stunden heiß diskutieren in der heutigen Sendung. Wie soll das weitergehen mit Musikdownloads und digitalen Rechten? Was ist überhaupt geistiges Eigentum? Und wie kann man das irgendwie, naja, verwertbar machen oder will man das überhaupt? Große philosophische Stunde heute also auch im Studio an die Müller Magun. Der Kollege Frank Rosengard und meine Person Max von Marlottky am Telefon der Markus. Hallo Markus. Namens.
Ähm, ja, naja, ich würde sagen, erst mal, dass es überhaupt keinen Sinn drin in was iTunes da bringt, weil 99 Cent für einen Song, ja, das ist nicht so bei demselben Preis, wie wenn ich mir einen Sampler kaufe, naja, oder keinen Sampler, sondern eine Single, die kostet 5 Euro.
Ja, aber da muss da ein Laden gehen.
Ja, da muss ich in den Laden gehen, aber...
Du fahrst nicht 5 Euro, sondern...
Ja, da hab ich was in der Hand. Hier hab ich nur einen Song, den, wenn ich den falschen Tastendruck mach, ist er gelöscht. Wird den an 90 Centes Wind geblasen und ich muss ihn wieder neu kaufen. So hab ich, wenn ich einen Single kauf, hab ich ihn in der Hand. Und, aber, naja, ich kauf halt nur einen Song. Und der Preis ist für mich derselbe. Und wieso soll ich das bezahlen, wenn ich einfach Kasan mach oder irgendeine andere Tauschbörse und lade ihn mir da runter?
Ich glaub, wenn du den verbrummelst, den Song, kannst du den noch mal umsonst runterladen. Ich glaub, der ist mit deiner Downloadliste verquickt. Für den hast du bezahlt.
Erstens das und zweitens könnte es ja sein, dass du ein moralischer Mensch bist und sagst, hey, das ist ein echt gutes Gefühl, dass ich nicht nur die Musik hören kann, sondern der Künstler auch seine Miete bezahlen kann und seine Musik auch weitermachen kann.
Ja, da wurde ja schon angesprochen, wie sie Spende, möchte ich es mal nennen. Das finde ich total okay.
Also das wird dir besser gefallen sozusagen?
Ja, würde ich auch sofort machen. Wenn es einen besseren Knopf gibt und da, weißt du nicht, gebe ich einfach noch mal eine Kreditkarnnummer ein und dann spende ich was dafür und dann kommt das auch sofort bei ihm an. Und nicht erst das 99 Prozent bei der Plattenfirma bleiben. Dann hätte ich nichts dagegen. Da gibt es genug Lieder und genug Gruppen, wo ich sagen würde, ja, den gebe ich mal fünf Euro und dann ist das in Ordnung. Aber ich finde doch die Preise für die Alben und so einfach zu hoch. Deswegen wird ja auch nur runtergeladen, weil sie einfach zu hoch sind, die Preise. Wenn die Preise niedriger, dann würden die Plattenzahlen garantiert steigen.
Aber glaubst du, dass es auch genug andere Leute gibt, die so ehrlich sind und es machen würden, dass es wirklich auch interessant ist, dass Künstler davon leben können?
Ja, das denke ich schon, weil ich bin relativ aktiv im Vorhang. Dort ist es so, dass, ich möchte jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber naja, da ging es darum, dass die Serverkosten bezahlt werden mussten. Bisher ging das nur über Werbung. Der Werbpartner hat aber wohl gekündigt. Nur haben die User gespendet und jetzt geht es weiter. Aber weil es ihnen halt was bringt, weil sie was davon haben, weil sie da so einen Sinn sehen, dafür zahlen sie auch. Und wenn man in der Sache einen Sinn sieht, ist das kein Problem, oder dass man sieht, was da von herkommt. Eine Pflichtabgabe, glaube ich, bringt es nicht.
Aber die Frage ist, das Problem ist bei Musik. Musik hörst du dir quasi im Zweifelsfall im kleinen Kämmerchen alleine an. Wenn du sowas hast, wo so ein Community-Wert dabei ist, du bist eben auf einer bestimmten Plattform zu Hause, das ist so der Server, auf dem du lebst, und dann sagt dir der auf einmal, hey, pass mal auf, wenn ihr jetzt nicht was tut, dann gibt es diese Plattform bald nicht mehr. Wenn dir der Künstler, wie soll der dir das klarmachen? Also du hast ein Musikstück bei dem gekauft, damit bist du ihm bekannt geworden, dann schickt er dir eine Mail und sagt zu dir, wenn ich weiter Musik machen soll, dann musst du mir jetzt wirklich mal was spenden oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ob das funktionieren würde.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein Problem, dass man da nur im stillen Kämmerlein sitzt. Aber ich glaube, mit der Spende hat es zu bringen. Oder die Preise halt senken, weil wie gesagt, 99 Cent für ein Song ist zu viel in meiner Meinung nach. Man hat die Internetkosten dann, nicht jeder hat DSL oder noch einen breiteren Anschluss, wo er dann fertig ist, das sind 99 Cent meiner Meinung nach zu hoch.
Okay, danke für den Anruf, Markus. Machet ihr gut, grüß nach Rostock. Und zu guter Letzt, der Christoph aus Kreuzberg, Berlin. Hallo Christoph.
Hallihallo.
Große These am Ende noch?
Na also ich frag mich, warum sich alle Leute so heiß für die Belange der Musikindustrie eigentlich interessieren. Also den Leuten wird ja eigentlich erzählt, Globalisierung, hin und her irgendwie Einschränkungen muss man ja in Kauf nehmen. Da frag ich mich, wenn jetzt eben der globale Informationsfluss zum Beispiel auch so ein Ausschluss der Globalisierung ist, wieso dann von der Industrie plötzlich Protektionismus, alle haben Angst, die Musikindustrie könnte kaputt gehen, auch wenn ich denke, dass das gar nicht der Fall ist. Durch die Kompaktkassette ist sie auch nicht kaputtgegangen. Um die Kutschenindustrie hat sich halt auch keiner geschehrt. Die sind halt auch mal kaputtgegangen, als das Automobil da war. Da war eine neue Zeit da und heute gibt es die halt nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, viele von der Kutschenindustrie haben umgesattelt, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Naja, das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit. Also ich meine, es heißt doch wirklich immer so, ja der Markt regelt alles irgendwie. Damit werden halt den Leuten eigentlich super viele Kompromisse verkauft und eigentlich Rückfall in frühe industrielle Zustände teilweise auch irgendwie von den Sozialsystemen legitimiert. Also wenn zum Beispiel Herr Dussmann sagt, die Bedingungen bei mir können ja scheiße gefunden werden, aber bei uns muss ja keiner arbeiten, wird ja keiner gezwungen, dann kann ich als Verbraucher eigentlich auch sagen, Leute, euch zwingt keiner Musik zu produzieren. Also sicher eine Menge Leute, die haben vielleicht ein Mediaequipment zu Hause und weiß der Kuckuck was und die produzieren dann ein paar Tracks und vielleicht finden die auch Leute schön und vielleicht gibt auch einer was dafür, vielleicht verkauft sich das auch. Aber muss der Staat sowas schützen, damit eine Industrie daraus einen Protektionismus betreiben kann?
Das ist eine interessante Frage als das, wenn man mit Juristen darüber philosophisch diskutiert, die auch eingestehen, dass das Urheberrecht insofern was Besonderes ist. Es ist ein sehr junges Recht und es ist zwar sozusagen, es ist für mich genau die Frage, ist es eigentlich Straf- oder Zivilrecht, ist gar nicht so einfach. Also da sind die sich selber kommend, die da immer in Definitionsschwierigkeiten, weil eben genau der Staat hier eigentlich etwas schützt, das genau genommen zivilrechtliche Angelegenheit ist. Und wie du richtig sagst, da kann man daran teilnehmen oder eben nicht.
Und es ist eben auch eine sozial-philosophische Frage, ob nicht ein freier Informationsfluss auch ein Grundrecht ist, was ich vielleicht die Gesellschaft gönnen mag.
Ja, das kollidiert ohnehin mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Aber was ist denn Musik anderes als Information?
Information sehe ich eher als eine abstrakste Sache. Also Information innerhalb eines Musikes wäre das, was ich dir jetzt so einfach erzählen kann, praktisch als Inhaltsangabe.
Das wäre die Information an der Musik. Nein, Musik transportiert viel mehr. Musik transportiert Stimmung. Musik kann ganz viele Dinge transportieren. Das ist alles Information.
Die Grauze ist jetzt sehr weit hergeholt im Grunde, aber das ist beliebig ausweitbar, zum Beispiel der neue Roman von John Grisham. Das ist auch Information. Da ist es noch näher. Da würde ich eher sagen, das ist Information. Das ist eine Geschichte, die mehr jemand erzählt. Das ist bei Musik genauso. Die erzählt ihr dir auf vielen Ebenen. Das ist das Problem, wie es ausgeweitet wird. Beim Urheberrecht ist es so, dass sehr stark definiert ist, welche Medien da gemeint sind, mit kopierbar, zitierbar und so. Das sind Tageszeitungen explizit genannt und vergängliche Medien und solche Sachen.
Das ist richtig, aber wobei das Werk als solches, bei einem Musikstück zum Beispiel, das Werk als solches gemeint ist, dieses Musikstück als Ganzes im Prinzip. Und Informationen können Anteile daraus sein.
Ich glaube, da bist du wirklich ein bisschen kontarevolutionär unterwegs. Da möchte ich wirklich nochmal diese Urheberrechtsmafia hier zitieren, die ja wirklich behaupten, Inhalte werden nur bei ausreichendem Urheber- und Leistungsschutz- Rechtsschutz angeboten. Das ist einfach mal ein Tineff. Der afrikanische Musiker, der sich da hinsetzt und auf die Trommel haut, der interessiert sich doch einen Kack dafür, ob da jetzt irgendwie ein juristischer Schutz dafür existiert oder ob er jetzt davon seine Miete zahlen kann, sondern der freut sich, wenn die Leute anfangen zu tanzen. Und viele ehrbare Musiker machen das auch.
Aber Andy, jetzt sei doch nicht so betriebsblind. Du weißt, bei dem einen geht es um die Musik, bei dem anderen geht es ums Geld. Das ist doch der ganze Trick dabei.
Gut, aber nehmen wir vielleicht nicht die Musik. Das ist vielleicht noch ein relativ schlechtes Beispiel. Nimm einen Film. Einfach Geld und das Geld muss irgendwie reinkommen, weil sonst gibt es halt keinen Film mehr.
Ja, ist ja richtig. Aber ich hab mir ja Matrix, kann ich ja auch öffentlich gestehen, hab ich mir also unlizenziert angeguckt, bei Freunden auf dem Beamer, keine Ahnung. Das haben die irgendwie aus dem Internet geholt. Und ich hab mir den da angeguckt. Und wenn er gut gewesen wäre, dann wär ich vielleicht auch noch mal ans Kino gegangen und hätte die Kohle bezahlt, diesen Matrix weiter. Aber ich fand den so schlecht, ich hab mir überlegt, also wenn jetzt mein Schwarzgucken dazu führt, dass solche Filme nicht mehr produziert werden, wunderbar. Wunderbar. Also dann bleibt das der Menschheit erspart?
Also ich fand den prima, um da mal gegenzuhalten. Ich fand den gut.
Oh und der bezahlt doch dafür.
Hab ich auch, ich war ja auch im Kino. Und ich gucke mir solche Filme auch gar nicht mehr an, weil in der Regel ist das eine von den Helligkeitswerten absolut überhöhte Kopie, die irgendein Typ abgefilmt hat. Wir hatten die Diskussion, du siehst dann, wie der Typ sich kurz bückt bei seinem Kumpel, irgendwie in die Popcorn-Tüte greift, wieder hochguckt und so. Das muss nicht sein.
In diesem Fall war das eine ganz ständige Kopie. Keine Ahnung, wo die die haben, aber...
Wahrscheinlich direkt abgescannt vor der Linse oder sowas.
Na ja, gut. Die Fragestellung, finde ich, ist schon berechtigt. Wo führt uns dieses Waiverrecht hin?
Richtig. Christoph, vielen Dank für den Anruf erst mal. Wir haben noch ein paar Infos in Sachen Chaos Computer Club, was die nächste Zeit anbelangt, insbesondere was das Camp anbelangt.
Ja, nee, nur ganz kurz noch. Normalerweise machen wir das ja immer nach einer Radiosendung. Haben wir uns da vorgenommen, dass wir euch auch noch einladen in den Datengarten, um das Thema noch mal im wirklichen Leben zu diskutieren. Leider musste er zu dieser Sendung ausfallen. Es liegt daran, dass ursprünglich sich für morgen die Firma IBM bei uns angekündigt hatte, um auf unsere TCPA-Forderungen einzugehen. Die haben aber wegen Krankheit und Bodennebel und überhaupt abgesagt, uns aber trotzdem eine Antwort auf diese TCPA-Geschichten zukommen lassen. Die habe ich leider, weil die mich wirklich erst gegen 20 Uhr per E-Mail erreicht hat, noch nicht lesen können, aber die gibt es sicherlich morgen bei uns im Internet. Und ja, wir werden dann irgendwie verkünden auf dem Chaosradio Ticker, wann die nächste Datengarten-Diskussion stattfindet.
Das holen wir das mal irgendwie nach, machen wir noch einen anderen Tempo, aber jetzt morgen wird es nicht sein.
Vielleicht kann man ja auch so einen kombinierten Tag machen.
Dafür haben wir noch was anderes, nämlich vom 7. bis 10. August machen wir das nächste... Jetzt übernehmen wir doch endlich.
Das Camp, wir gehen zelten.
Das Chaos Communication Camp.
Da kommen irgendwie 2000 oder 3000 Leute hin, ganz viele Leute, die bringen ihre Zelte mit in ihre Computer und die gehen da auf den Acker.
Und ihre Kinder und ihre Freundinnen und ihre Badesachen und irgendwie einen Grill und...
Oder auch keine Badesachen.
Das ist doch ein See, wir haben doch ein Badesee.
Ja, weißt du, beim letzten Mal haben sich die Nachbarn auch besperrt, dass da irgendwie Leute nackt rumgelaufen wären und sich befummelt hätten.
Ja, mit Badesachen meinte ich natürlich ein Handtuch, Mensch.
Jungs, ihr verkauft das mal wieder so gut, als wäre das was, dass man sich selber ein Messer ins Knie rammen muss. Das ist eine unheimlich tolle Geschichte.
Ihr setzt noch ein bisschen Musik und ihr guckt dabei auf www.ccc.de slash camp.
Also ich würde schon sagen, wie toll das ist, weil ich will ja dieses Jahr auch mal hingehen und ich muss einfach mal sagen, da werden diverse Wettbewerbe laufen, ihr könnt da auch meinetwegen online zocken, ihr könnt sehen, wie irgendwelche Typen irgendwas hacken, programmieren, machen und tun, wie Leute ein Radio da machen, da wird Live-Radio gemacht werden von Leuten über dieses Thema. Da werden Vorträge gehalten und das ist einfach mal geil, weil man innerhalb von, was weiß ich, drei Tagen?
Vier Tage machen wir das.
Also innerhalb von einer Anzahl von Tagen, die man an einer Hand abzählen kann, unheimlich tolle Sachen gemacht werden und ich würde es euch einfach nur empfehlen, da mal vorbeizuschauen, weil es ein Einblick ist, den man sonst nie bekommt. Also das sind einfach Sachen, da lernt man innerhalb von fünf Tagen so viel, wie man sonst in drei Jahren über heise.de nicht erfahren kann.
Und die Atmosphäre ist einfach großartig. Internet haben wir auch irgendwie. Mal gucken, wie viel, aber es wird viel sein.
Ich dachte Wireless-Learn auf dem ganzen Gelände, oder?
Ja, es geht ja um die Außenanbindung und die, denke ich mal, wird auch angemessen sein.
Okidoki. Also wirklich empfehlenswert www.ccc.de slash camp und ihr könnt Badesachen mitbringen, auch wenn hier schon wieder die Wellen hochschlagen, weil ihr damals einer von der Nachbarschaft Ärger gemacht habt. Das ist jetzt einfach mal egal, Jungs. Und wir verabschieden uns, wünschen euch viel Spaß. Das war's mit dem Chaosradio 82. Ausgabe. Wenn ihr noch was habt, was ihr sagen wollt, dann macht das per Mail 82 at chaosradio.ccc.de und da kriegt ihr noch die Infos, die Andi sicherlich nachreichen möchte. Wenn ihr euch da meldet, dann kriegt ihr die auch einfach zugeschickt. Wir sagen Tschüss und geben ab an den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Macht's gut.
Ach so, ja, Tschüss. Wiederhören. Und? Und ich könnte jetzt dann noch sagen, dass Kopierschutzmechanismen, Schutzmechanismen sind dann wirksam, wenn, das ist wirklich lustig, bla bla bla Verzerrung oder sonstige Unwahl, die die Erreichung des Schuchsziels sicherstellen.
Der Kopierschutz ist dann wirksam.
Also wirksam, wenn das wirksam ist. Aber das ist natürlich, also der Gesetzgeber ist wirklich auch lustig drauf.
Wir dekonstruieren uns einfach weiterhin selbst und wünschen viel Spaß. Bis zum nächsten Letzten mit Rob!